[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to ultimate blitz
challenge here at the st louis chess
club the capital of chess in america
we're on day two of the ultimate blitz
and yesterday was absolutely thrilling
the question on everybody's mind can
gary still hang absolutely he played
great yesterday he wasn't rewarded
because of warm blunders and big
mistakes and critical moments but i'm
looking forward to a fantastic day of
chess
and let's take a look at our cast for
this
once in a lifetime event here gary
kasparov is playing against the top
three players in the u.s championship
and as fate would have it the top three
in the tournament finished in first
through third our new us champion
fabiano caruana
nakamura and so and the standings we got
nakamura and so tied for the lead but it
is very tight kasparov just half a point
behind and carolina still well within a
reaching distance with three and a half
let's take a look at the format here
we've got a series of round robins every
day three yesterday three today the time
control is five minutes with a three
second delay oftentimes books played
with an increment delay you never get
any time back you can't make a bunch of
moves to gain time like you can with
increments exactly
and it's not all just for fun here it is
worth 50 000 in prize money here first
place will take home 20 000 for the
players who already won big checks in
the u.s championship a nice little
cherry on top
but gary kasparov
has generously agreed to donate his
winnings to the us chess olympic team
and guess what the three players who
he's fighting against will be on that
team and how sweet it is isn't it
so you win or you win
yeah it's a win-win for the american
players and a big thank you
uh to gary kasparov for supporting our
teams
and we've got grandmaster maurice ashley
for a little insight on what happened
yesterday and what we're going to see
today
well an exciting day one of action
absolutely and what could be more
exciting than a day two we get another
chance at this it's incredible watching
these players and in particular gary
kasparov yesterday he was a little bit
off his game but he played some
wonderful chess and we expect to see
more excitement here today well let's
see the lineup how the players did first
of all the u.s champion
fabiano caruana he started off okay in
the tournament but then he got derailed
by the end he lost three games in a row
we'll see whether or not he can get it
together and come back he's still
absolutely within a stone's throw of
first place but it's the big dog the man
himself gary kasparov hosting the show
he just played wonderful chess people
are dreaming about a gary come back the
way he played well he's going to try to
show the youngsters today that
yesterday's fluke of his three nights
gambit that is dropping three nights
blundering them in his games was history
is history now and he's gonna look to
put the pedal on and show what kind of
comeback kid he could be but he's gonna
have to catch these gentlemen first of
all grandmaster wesley so people didn't
look at him as one of the favorites in
the event but guess what luck smiled on
him yesterday he was able to pick up a
couple of games from blunders and now
he's in a tie for first place so he'll
be looking to see if he can solidify his
standing right now and show that he
should be the deserved winner but he
will have to compete with his co-leader
hikaru nakamura one of the best in blitz
on the planet he did not play well by
his own standards yesterday but expect
him to come back fighting strong knowing
that if he wins he'll be the winner of
ultimate blitz and there he is his game
face on as we go into day two of the
action that's right into bragging rights
ultimate bragging rights and blitz
absolutely and
what we saw in day one jen
was the players leapfrogging one another
you saw that wesley started with two
losses was totally in the basement and
then he
turned it around and he's a co-leader
with the players so bunched up and the
games come coming so quickly that
leaderboard can change
literally uh in a single round that's
right no clear leader and i i really
think it's anyone's game today but
what's your prediction yasser gary
really i mean gary played just such an
amazing chess yesterday but i think it's
actually unfair to say he had three
night blunders he actually blundered
four nights
the the fourth was to nakamura because
of the touch move incident nakamura
decided not to call it right and he
ended up drawing that game right just
think about that
two uh wesley so's victory in this
tournament were were against uh gary and
both of those victories came from knight
blunders that gary was winning simply
give those two games to gary and he's
our attorney so it's only half a point
that he could that he would have saved
for nakamura where he would have gotten
two full points from wesley so i agree
with you that and it is very hard
looking at the way that gary played
chess yesterday just so beautiful the
concepts the aggressive moves and
sacrifices that he made under time
pressure just really incredible yeah the
mix the mixture of his ability to play
strategically his ability to play
tactically
to defend to aggress and attack
and these guys that he's pushing around
let's not forget that all three are in
the top ten and fabiana carry one is
number two
and he's in last place and here's wesley
so looking very casual he got the memo
do not wear long sleeves especially not
a jacket
he learned quick well yeah he has a lot
of respect for yasser so i'm quite sure
that he caught wind of what yaza was
saying you know
speaking of intensity gary kasparov i
saw him at our kingside diner earlier
today
and it looked like he was about to
checkmate the eggs
because he was just like he was just so
intense it looked like he was already
playing a chess game he was actually
like sitting there with his head in his
hands like i guess maybe going over some
of the his opening preparation in his
head blindfold but it was really
incredible and i can imagine that um it
would be scary for players that aren't
of this caliber to sit across the table
from him without question and just
imagine that he's been retired for 11
years and all of that intensity and
energy that he
put brought to the game
uh at his peak he was formidable and to
sit across the board from him you felt
his intensity and there we have the u.s
champion fabiana cariwana who by the way
was playing uh s chess yesterday and bug
house as well i was playing a little
duck house with gabby we were having a
lot of fun he was relaxing i will say
that nakamura looks like he really has
come to play today yesterday he seemed
to treat the event kind of casually no
big deal but i think now his attitude
has shifted you see him sitting at the
board before anyone else the way he was
walking around i think he understands
that this is an important event for him
he wants to prove that he's the best
blitz player in the united states for
sure clearly he's number two in the
world in the live rankings right now
behind magnus carlson i think though
that everyone loved this the
twitterverse was crazy with
talk about blitz chess how great it was
how much action
everyone there were something like 108
000 unique viewers
watching this match from yesterday
watching the action which just goes to
show that this is just thrilling stuff
and more of these kind of events should
happen in the future
because the fans want it i totally agree
with you more memories absolutely sorry
i mean this is the time to show your
girlfriend your husband who doesn't play
chess to um try to get them excited and
see what it's all about absolutely
absolutely as you see the fans streaming
in now
it is a friday
and some kids in the audience should be
in
off excuse me good day i want to come i
want to come watch this stuff so
clearly the players have enthralled
everyone and we just expect more of this
fun stuff this is just unbelievable
chess the best thing is the best show in
town i was watching uh some of the some
of the twitter comments and one was like
thank god for chess because we get to
see this now by the way in reference to
your point about nakamura i don't
believe him for a second when he says
that he doesn't take this seriously i
think that's absolutely absurd he wants
to win this so bad as soon as he found
out that he could it was very unlikely
that he would win the u.s championship
he had this title on his mind nakamura
you can't believe every word he says
well but if he was dead serious totally
serious he would not have let gary off
the hook yesterday yesterday's flop by
gary when gary let go of the piece if
naca was so bent on winning this event
at all costs you know if magnus carlson
let go he would have said excuse
me go that's it i think he thinks he's
gonna win any different attitude about
it and i know now i think though he's
settled in and he wants to win this now
and it's a great position for him he did
not play well yesterday clearly by his
standards what we've seen he did not
play great and guess what he's tied for
first what happens if he brings his a
game today what if he'll run away with
it what if he and gary bring their a
game then we're gonna see some
absolutely brilliant defense by nakamura
some quick play
and of course uh just uh sizzling
openings and conceptions but that's what
nakamura i think has that you also see
in caruana um just incredible defensive
skills in brits absolutely no question
about it jen the well all of these
players are just uh what can i say the
best of the best and gary like you say
is analyzing
getting prepared
and
maurice and i will recall of course when
gary takes off his watch
he came in which he has done earlier he
came to play and when he put the watch
on it meant the game was over and there
we go they're off and it looks like he's
playing a modern
perk defense
wow gary
is a transpose to a king's indian after
this move c4
strange that wesley didn't go for some
other lines and it hasn't
taking the position into original lines
this move and not the common move
this was a favorite favorite opening i
used to play a favorite defense i would
play in this position knight c6 and my
idea of course is to capture this knight
on f3 followed by capturing the pawn on
d4 and if they played the move d5 to do
the same thing to capture this knight
and then to occupy the square d4 and
knight
d2 that's an unusual move absolutely
right out of the opening we're getting
something
very very different now everybody and
his brother plays e5 in this position
with the idea that after d5 you drop
back with the knight to d7 and you
transpose into a king's indian where
this knight on d2 is utterly misplaced
we'll see if that
happens that way of course the bishop on
g4 is not a happy camper he doesn't want
to trade itself off normally in the
king's india and so you see there after
it was attacked gary dropped it back to
d7 that's the bishop you want to retain
but at some point it looks like he's
going to get an f5 can he get it in
without well it doesn't look as though
he can get it in without developing his
knight just yet he might be able to play
h6 and go for it it'll be nice gaining a
tempo if he could play this move f5
without having to bring the knight out
castle and move the knight again and
then get it so that that pawn f7 f5 is
the move that gary's going to be looking
for and c5 already whoa
c5 c5 with the idea that if you take we
can play knight c4 start ganging up in
that e pawn i love that move trying to
throw gary off right away in the opening
and gary realizes it yes
he's doing what i would and play f6 just
throw down the challenge you're the one
who sacrificed the pawn let's see how it
goes so now if we play d6 you just uh
just put your you you can just go knight
i'd say
i think you've got to go knight c8
because if you go knight c6 we can take
on c7 and play knight d6 check anyway
that's
your knight will have to leave and the
knight will come back so one mp7 though
i think wesley's just going to play
bishop e3 and slow play it yeah like as
a pawn sacrifice right and then we have
defects in the cards anyway exactly yeah
that's exactly right so hold on a second
in this position b5 is an idea he has
played d6 and i drop back to ca so we're
seeing this critical line d6 knight drop
back and now the move bishop to e3
that is an interesting variation the
point being that the knight on g8 cannot
get in the game and white is threatening
the pawn on c5 the question is what if
b5 right now and he's played b6 being
very solid b5 didn't i guess didn't lead
anywhere but
but this move b6 after castles white is
way ahead in development black has to
figure out how to unravel his pieces
well it's very simple maurice you just
play knight h6 in such positions you
bring your knight to f7 and you quickly
and i mean quickly get your king out of
the center and again these pieces on the
king side white's pieces the bishop on
e3 bishop on e2 knight on f3
are not
major actors in this type of structure
where black is blockading with his pawns
on e5 and c5
personally
it's easier to play wesley's position
but
uh i actually
like
black's extra pawn and gary played the
move bishop to c6
attacking the pawn
i like that move too attacking the pawn
on e4
as well as now
threatening the pawn on d6 three times
that's right and stopping any kind of
little ideas like queen d5 that we might
have in the position right so now the
engines are giving takes on c7 right now
after all that pawn is hanging and he
has to take and capture back by gary and
now the move b4 wesley insisting on
playing incredibly sharp chest on every
move and gary shaking his head because
wesley will not let him develop any
pieces without
aggression on the board that's right now
he just can't develop his knight because
c5 is hanging but if he takes on b4 then
a rook will go to c1 and that is his
plan wesley on every move it looks like
wesley's intends on opening up the game
playing gambit chess and forcing
kasparov to think and kasparov boldly
just taking the pawn anyway
capture did in fact occur and now rook
to c1
that he did not play 97 just yet that
move has not been played just yet so
what kind of exactly what is wesley's
plan
can we keep that king in the center that
was why i wanted to go knight h6 and f7
wesley is not letting gary breathe every
single move he's throwing down a new
challenge a new sacrifice wesley's idea
is to play queen b3 and he's done that
and 97 queen b3 is on the board so you
don't want to castle right now because
of a terrific discovery by that night
it's queen on the long diagonal
preventing the king from castling how
will he get out of the center that is
and the engines by the way are giving a
huge edge to white right now saying that
white is crushing black by a full piece
according to the engines because the
black king is stuck in the middle of the
board eight six that's not making any
progress
in this position
how do we build up the position is white
we can just play rook to d1 or
i like that just play rook d1 and at
some point
you got to be careful about removing the
knight from c4 and sticking a bishop on
b5 that is absolutely right this
position is huge for white full
compensation for two pawns down
but the question is i'm trying to get
into gary's head what was he thinking
about with this move h6 he can't he
can't be thinking about playing f5
opening up the position
what is this about
more sacrifices than every single game
knight a5 is completely crushing but
this is bad as well this is all so bad
that c6 bishop we're threatening bishop
c6 and queenie's six jack what about
just queen e6 right now exactly
everything is bad for him he just played
rook to ba forcing the trade
it looks like queen e6 won't work
right now
but there's got to be a death blow
well you can take on c6 and and then
take play queen e600
renewing the threat wesley's playing
incredible chess that was the engine's
first unbelievable challenge
choice choice so far gorgeous attacking
games
it's just astonishing the way he's
completely dismantling kasparov in this
game he is playing just sacrificial
chess he's playing the style of tao
you're looking at this right now
beautiful fantastic game so far and gary
missed i think kerry missed b4 because
you can see as soon as the move before
happened he was already like whoa i
wasn't expecting that is queen b7 he's
like
queen to b7 is on the board queen beast
oh my goodness b7 rook season 66
yeah
if he finds that this is the other game
which uh is not nearly as exciting he's
gonna find rick six
rooks
and bam there it is yeah wow
so playing one of the gorillas
now he's played bishop c5 and he's just
threatening bishop takes c6 this is i
mean bishop
this is
the duke
unbelievable chess this is why gary
knows it now he's completely busted what
an amazing display by wesley and now
taking on e7 and resigns
what are you seeing here i mean kudos to
wesley so he just ripped gary apart in
that game you can look at this game fro
from just studying move by move and
wesley instantly playing genius chess
incredible wow those of you who've been
on wesley in this match who believed in
the underdog give yourselves a big pat
on the back because that game was the
game of the ultimate blitz so far oh
absolutely i mean the shot game is one
of the most amazing amazing blitz games
i've ever seen in my league my life
hands down
all right let's take a look at this now
though at least to get to you know try
to do our jobs after seeing that it's
just unbelievable but let's get to the
other game where
where this is slightly better for black
according to the engines this position
is slightly better for black that c4
break in and there's hikaru and way
ahead on the clock is ikaru so clearly
the leaders have come to play as well
caruana with only 34 seconds left
hikaru with two minutes but what is he
thinking about right now hg6 is it
automatically i mean what was that about
it's been so long on that move no i mean
that was shocking
and always guys i i'm in shock i really
am i
i need to recover from well let's try it
let's try to get this going right now
we've got
two minutes to finish this game so we'll
just keep it just on this one
right now the thread looks like looks
like black is still slight edge the
engines are giving the moves c3 with the
idea of now rope takes on d4 and rook b8
and there it is that has occurred
certainly nakamura with a strong pawn on
c3 how do you fight against it the
indication
is only exactly you've got to stop rook
b2 which would absolutely overwhelm
and oh and that you know
it looks like a three would be played
yeah
you know rook a2 had a strange sacrifice
queen a2 that doesn't seem like it
worked because of rook d6 at the end i
mean rook d8 at the end right so queen
a2 queen a2 and then rook d8 but now
he's allowed to move rook b2 maybe he
overlooked that tactic rook b2 queen c1
and now now the game is terrible for
white i mean look at this position hold
on this f2 pawn looks like a real what
do you do about queen b6 exactly queen
b6 is lights out queen b6 is busted
queen b6
just
attacking the rook preparing to get the
c pawn down the board is not only f2 but
being able to play c2 as well so
this is why he didn't find it he played
three instead he played rook to be three
did not find this move and he played
rook
to a4
white is back into the game
white is back nakamura missed queen b6
which would have been winning on the
spot we're okay for with the idea now
playing rook c4 trying to get behind the
pass pawn a very thematic idea yeah the
game has shifted dramatically the game
is just dramatically he went from losing
to now white is okay
and the time when he was up so much
nakamura it was how is it that he's now
almost even
that is an amazing and and what a
turning point now we're back to b2 but
there he is he knows exactly what's
inside
c4 rook c4
and queen b6 kind of
kind of putting pressure on the uh four
four is another four shut down
the pawn nakamura shaking his head there
he realizes he's messing up and he's had
to play this move to equalize the game
and he still has a pass a pawn however
but queen d4 actually no queen d4 he
loses his apartment
he's got to be a draw queen is a must he
cannot try to play this through and he
did go for it and he's now just
expecting it to be a draw he's taken on
e4 that's right and i think they both
realize this is just a dead draw now
no reason to keep playing
so going on it's just making moves he's
still making moves though there's an
offer of a trade another move
and it looks like nakamura trying to
play quickly even though he's worse on
the clock nakamura is a bit frustrated i
think that he didn't win this game he's
came to play better today and maybe not
too pleased wait a minute guys queen f6
somebody may be overpressing themselves
no i'd still draw yeah you're right no
g5 that's equal why are the players
this is such a dead draw they're still
going they're still making moves it
doesn't make any sense waiting for some
kind of blunder but there is finally and
that means wisely so in the clear lead
of the ultimate st louis um sorry wesley
we love you but most of us couldn't have
he was so deserving that was
that was phenomenal that was amazing i
mean i meant of course that nobody
believed that he would be leading the
tournament at the stage
this was only his most uh heart art and
fans who know his blitz skills i mean
playing like you mentioned it morphy
with those double pants everywhere cross
and sacrifice after sacrifice
literally he didn't give gary a chance
to breathe maurice you've got to show
some highlights of that incredible
incredible game
absolutely the sacrifice is just
abounded in this game first of all it
started with this move c5 this is an
idea you see sometimes in the king's
indian thematic idea gary took the first
pawn the knight c4 now the move f6
compromising this bishop somewhat now d6
trying to break through and then bishop
to e3 after b6 castles bishop to c6 by
gary look at this sequence takes takes
and b4 you want another pawn you can
have it so that's pawn number one now
pawn number two gary accepted tried to
develop but queen b3 stopping him from
castling and gary's going to regret this
move 8-6 although he's definitely worse
already rook d1 b5
let's sacrifice again so it was two
pawns now it's a knight and after fe 5
bishop takes b5 rook b8 bishop a4 well
we saw the finish here rook c6 and then
queen e6 97 bishop c5 just gorgeous
chess
okay we're going to try to get this out
our minds and gary look at his reaction
as these moves were cascading down like
bombs from on high the way he was hit
and here's the score
wesley so six points in clear first
place ahead of hikaru nakamura with gary
at four and a half and karana at four
well there's still
would have been eight rounds to go
can the commentators take it and they
have started can the fans take it and
yes we are underway gary kasparov
against nakamura let's take a look at
that game the the stunner and last game
of course b4 just dazzling move by so
and gary's back to the scotch
he's played this in in day one and so
he's the players have been well warned
that gary is looking for open dynamic
forcing
theoretical lines as well except for
last game the only game that he didn't
go for like a main line theory he ended
up getting absolutely crushed
back to playing main line he didn't fall
back to his uh
usual kings indian defense instead he
played this offbeat system with knight
c6 and it just backfired in dramatic
fashion and this they battled in this
one
takes
last round as well yeah this is a major
major uh pawn sacrifice theoretical pawn
sacrifice that gary trail blazed he
usually plays knight d2 and follows
through
with um
ideas of knight to b5 and both of those
moves have happened knight d2 queen back
to g6 and now knight b5 exactly and
that pawn on c7 is awkward you have to
either defend it with your king or just
ditch it and nakamura has decided to
ditch it
in
in blitz it's such a big advantage to
have the initiative it's much much
harder to play defensive chess and look
at this move bishop h5 is trying to
prove that that queen is awkwardly
placed but is a very unusual way of
attacking
from the side like that i mean move like
bishop d3 automatically
h5
machine workout has trick queen trout a
bunch of times
carrie might be trying to push the knife
barry was blundering knights but but
nacho was
by the way in the other game wesley
seoul's already ahead by a pawn in a
line that is a typical sacrifice in the
opening black is okay here looking for
counter play so though up upon
for the moment black's pieces are
dynamically placed look at white's
pieces the rook on a1 the bishop on c1
those two pieces not working at all
while black already has complete
development and white will have to
consolidate this position it also has to
fight against the light square bishop
black has the two bishops but in
particular that light square bishop is
where he has the edge and we see this
trade here now to move knight to d5
hoping to see a trade i don't think
you're going to see that happen that
queen is going to move and it did queen
to e5
in this position challenging that knight
and saying i've got the two bishops and
now
bishop to e3 looking to trade if he
could get bishop takes e3 on the board
then
he should be okay white he is up upon
after all absolutely
good move by by
wesley and he's playing really well i
mean look at the times as well almost a
minute ahead on the clock it's very
significant and
he's gotten rid of the two bishops so
slowly but surely uh
flabby's uh dynamic
counter play that he's counting on uh
for the pawn sacrifice is ebbing away he
does seem solid take a look back at the
game with casparo absolutely he has
played a move f4 in the position f4 just
preceded this sequence right here he
played f4 which is a sacrifice because
bishop e3 was in the position and queen
e5 would have been possible but it looks
as though gary had some play in that
line with knight to c4 the back end of
that
on the tail end of that i should say
right but so instead he played the move
knight to g4 did nakamura forcing well
gary hasn't moved yet he was surprised
by this move
and the engines are saying you have to
take on g4 and go into an end game
pretty much the only way to play the
position everything else is losing he
must trade on g4 i don't think gary felt
like he wanted to do that to go into
this ending with takes on g4 but this is
what the inches are saying he'd have a
decent position just because of a
sequence like the one you're describing
there yeah that's right knight on c7
makes a poor impression now it's sort of
like
why are we there
in the first place i mean let's let's
find a better square like the d6 square
and you can also move it back to b5
and attack a7 and play to d6 it does
look though
that in a very
uh theoretical battle
hikaru is holding his own and we are
seeing these moves on the board bishop
g4 queen g4 being played now after
bishop c5 pawn c5
um
do we have to do we have to play 94
right away or maybe we should try to i
sorry i've got auto on my board so let
me just uh
flash back and forth by the way that
game of wesley so looks like he's really
playing gorgeous chess with that knight
on e3 very very solid and upon to the
good
so
here we go do we want to play queenie
one i'm not a big fan of queenie one
i i think you got to take that bishop
and then gary he played knight c4 he's
been a long time realizing that his
compensation is really in the end game
he has no choice here
he could trade queens he's offering a
trade here he's not declining it in any
way it looks as though the trade
must be effectuated after this move
he could also move his queen back
apparently back to d7 the engines give
and he has done so queen back to d7
avoiding the trade i think gary
probably is happy not to see a trade but
at the same time this move might have
come as a surprise to him and he's at
218 on the clock
still okay still within bounds but he's
gonna have to find an idea quickly and
looks like nakamura
is playing at a nice pace well nakamura
could trade queens here now with bishop
take c5 if he wants because you can't
take on c7 because we have bishop takes
d6 and then after queen takes c4 the um
the knight on e7 hangs right so if i
play bishop c5 you're compelled to take
with the pawn and then i can trade
queens anyhow well gary's not going to
be very happy with the outcome of that
because the knight on c and he's done
what you suggested jen but that knight
on c7 is looking
out of
place that's right because this is
actually worse than the version we were
looking at before because we don't have
that we don't have access to that b5
square immediately but we do have the
option of playing knight e5
um trying to tickle the bishop on d7 and
then extricating our night exactly by
the way as this goes into an end game in
the other game wesley so sacrificed back
the pawn on the b2 square he did a
sacrifice and
black
took it he said i'll take it in this
position take a look at what happened
here he played this move queen e5 just a
couple of moves ago he played queen to
e5 so well let's go fast forward here
queen b5 queen there right there he gave
up this pawn
on b2 and
fabi said i'll take it and now this
sequence and black is perfectly fine now
black is happy
with the shattered structure black is
very happy with the structure and
suddenly wesley's got his head in his
hands he realized
having an advantage up a pawn to giving
the pawn back and suddenly he has
nothing and look at his knight being
dominated by the bishop on e6 you expect
to move g6 soon by black and then the a2
pawn could come under fire as well
wesley so did not manage his position
very well and he's hesitating unlike in
the last game this is what's so crazy
about blitz you could play one great
game but hey the next game
you could
lay an egg and right now he's not
playing fantastically but he's still
trying to fight as he trades queens and
plays rook to b5 wow
that game is is heating up
definitely the game with hikaru has
tapered off i mean with all of these
trades but gary did a very interesting
uh maneuver here in this moment i had
expected gary to play rook on f1 e1
instead he attacked the bishop
and then he played f5
yes putting the bishop to the f5 square
in g4 square and just had played f5 and
guess what he's got a trap
of the bishop in mind
interesting little little
subtle nuance it sounds like nakamura's
made movies just attack the knight on c7
and that's going to be nice for gary
gary's going to leap out of that c7
square he's looking for 96 exactly
much better outpost on d6 than on c7
absolutely i'm playing him right now
forced to play
his bishop the now after h3 bishop h5 we
can stick our bishop on f7 but boy does
it look like some things are hanging in
the air here for well i would definitely
put you know plant that knight on d6 and
then uh instead of playing the move h3
uh gen i'll go for rookie four and g4 i
want to hunt down that bishop and take
it because that bishop could find a
beautiful outpost on d5 well it's not
easy though you're right what you just
said those knights the white knights
look like they're both fighting for the
same square on d6 the idea of the
superfluous knight and so these knights
after this movie
as he has played right into d6 and now
rook to c7 guarding the position but
that knight on c4
it's stable for now but sooner or later
he's gonna have to play a move like a4
the difficulty in this position is how
to improve the position as as white what
are your next three moves okay we can
play knight e3 and um
he has played a4 yes he's just played
before it's a beautiful move of his
strategical move to uh prevent any b5
and bishops draw back rookie four rookie
four i had i'd expected rookie for a4 by
the way but he's just transposed and now
rook to d8
because he's uh hikaru's got to get rid
of that knight and knight is just uh
two rooks
both sides with doubled rooks and there
goes one night off the board as gary has
ripped that off and gary with only 36 34
seconds left on the clock his time is
ticking down
actually 36 seconds left 50 seconds left
for nakamura white looks optically great
but how does he improve and what does
black do they both look like
there's not much to do in the position
for either side maybe rookie 6 and a5
and a6 wow a6 that's a big this is big
a5
just kills the queen side now i don't
like that move a6 at all by ikaru but
following up with g6 which seems to
weaken another pawn
well he had to do something and now the
rook over to f1
eyeballing the king g5 ideas could come
he's traded and he's taken with the rook
and now rook to d5
trying to trade gary said uh-uh backing
the rook up rook d5 rook back to f3 and
now king to g7 and how does white do it
a rook now on e6 yeah we've been trying
to play that for a while exactly jen
this is getting heated but now the
knight can come back into g6 isn't that
going to be crushing when we get our
knight back
no you guys knight's going to be or e3
and well
d6 f5 or e3
h3 93 rook d2 check you didn't want to
see right away but you took a nice idea
yeah king g3 first yeah and
can gary do it with only 20 seconds on
the clock knock over try to save herself
and now knight back attacking the rook
rook has to leave he can't hesitate he's
got to play quick moves both sides have
to start playing quick moves tonight
back to c6 now they're repeating
repeating once trying to gain a little
time but now let's play rookie 7 check
he's playing for the win
gary declined the
he's done it
very very nice and that night on c4 we
hope gary doesn't blunder that night you
got to be careful what happened
yesterday
and by the way knight e3 to f5 is
looming large but that's why i'm
wondering about 95 and he's stopped oh
and now forced train a four straight
after rook to dc
now the knight in the position and look
at the clocks now 96 same idea we're
threatening knight f5 i thought he was
not going to win only
only 10
make that his time is ticking down seven
seconds six seconds he needs a move king
back to f8 and gary's staying ahead on
the clock nice monster he's rook down
into the position now a capture of pawns
and now naka is going fast
h4
but
will black have a chance as well he's
brought his knight back no way that pawn
is on h6 whoa
this looks awful there's checkmating
patterns but but he can't find the mate
because of that knight and knight back
to g6
oh my knockout with only five seconds
but he's just playing so quickly gary
repeating moves and now taking upon rook
to d2
again repeating moves but he's not
getting anything what just happened what
just happened like gary just forgot to
hit the clock well they're going so fast
getting behind the pawn looking nervous
oh
both sides with this pawn how does gary
make any progress here he's repeating
moves he doesn't see how he's played
what what was wrong with
why did he allow this pawn to go another
step a-2 oh he's queening so he's not
nothing worried about nakamura totally
under control knowing again
amazing
i think gary had some great chances and
i'll just tell you what i think as soon
as
the game gets registered on my screen
first of all let's go to the wesley cell
game and i'll show you what i think was
a critical moment
hikaru getting lucky
in this second round of
the challenge but a big result the other
game wesley won the game he won the game
goodness incredibly wow
wesley yet again
putting some distance between himself
and the rest of the field as caruana is
tumbling down now having lost what seems
like four losses in five games he lost
three in a row yesterday to close out
the event that he drew this mor this
first game and he's lost again so his
chances are looking completely dismal
right now but it's wesley so
rising
like a phoenix i mean he had two
games that he lost in the beginning of
the tournament
but look what he's this comeback he's
made and now at seven points the only
player remotely close to him is nakamura
at six
gary kasparov at five
many points behind but there's seven
rounds to go
wow that's right but wesley is so just
astonishing us indeed
wow oh and now you get the the
post-mortem analysis
well the main line is not 666 all right
let's just go back actually
okay
okay
well gary looks like he's enjoying
himself maybe you should play a little
bit more often gary some of your fans
online are would be quite excited about
that exactly i just wanted to say that
here is where i thought that gary could
have really taken control with a very
very nice move just at this moment if he
had played
rook f5
forcing this knight to the e6 square
where really it's only playing a
defensive role then switched his rook
over these two dominating pieces the
knight on c4 and the rook on d5 followed
by h4 this knight will be perpetually
frozen that was key
and in blitz knights rule everyone knows
that knights are the thing we've seen
gary drop knights yesterday today look
what wesley did with his knight in this
position it was a dead even position
fabiano with the draw in hand if he
plays correctly but he played this
disastrous move king to d8 allowing the
knight to hop in and now you can't move
your king anywhere if you go here check
the knight fork and if you attack his
rook thanks for your rook and the knight
is guarding the rook so even number two
players in the world
fall for night forks those nights are
tricky and blitz and they started again
so we will see how this round three
transpires today that's right we've got
a gary against fabiano and our our
leader um assault facing off against
nakamura this will be a big test and it
looks like we've got a grunfeld on top
absolutely uh and if wesley
keeps the form that he's produced in
these first two games
this tournament could be over i mean he
has been
amazing but you know with seven rounds
to go you could easily drop three in a
row in blitz so don't count your lucky
stars just as the us champion has done
so already wesley himself dropped two so
he knows you can lose games nakamura
drop games as well
everybody can lose in this it's blitz
there's that's why we love it so much
because there's so many story lines that
keep happening as you play the games and
just look how quickly
uh wesley has has played i mean he just
knows this variation of the groomfeld
inside and out it's like uh
karu is so used to being a head on the
clock and look already just
well
six seconds and let's talk about this uh
this opening i mean f3 grunfeld is a
line where a lot of times when you play
three f3 people play the grunfeld who
wouldn't normally play the groomfeld so
sometimes they're planning on playing
the king's indian but against this
variation it will switch and with the
castling on opposite sides who do you
prefer playing because
um it looks like white's getting a quick
attack but at the same time doesn't have
a lot of miners to work with
yeah i i this is a very complicated line
i've played it as white not as black and
i've recognized that the counter play
especially based on this move e6
is annoying because once this bishop
gets out either to the e6 or even to the
f5 square it's white's king that comes
under heavy pressure
and although it's a little bit awkward
we can see that this move rook d7 by
wesley isn't ideal now he played bishop
f4 actually just just tickling them on
on c7 and then after rook d7 he then
went for bishop h6 a lot of what white
is trying to do is based on a king side
attack based on the move h5 and look at
these but we see a quick cr trait of
queens actually here so we didn't want
to see the movie h5 and um all of the
forces coming towards his king so we
played this queen f8 move that's very
important when you're getting attacked
you've got to look for ways to bring
your queen into the defense that's
absolutely because you know what if he
doesn't trade queens the queen can stick
on g7 and it's gonna be quite powerful
from that square a big development in
the other game gary kasparov playing his
sicilian trademark sicilian against
fabiano caron and look with caruana that
he said here i come i'm going to go down
the board take a look at this position
yeah he allowed the move b4 and knight
a4 he did not have to allow it a couple
of moves ago right just before this if
you go back just a couple of moves he
had the option after the move b5 to play
a3 to slow down the counter play of
course that allows rook v8 and the
possible b4 anyway so he said you know
what i'm going to ignore it but the
minus of that is allowing this move b4
and knight a4 and now the move e5 which
gary did playing like i think he knows a
thing or two about the sicilian defense
bishop back to e3 now takes on f4 and
knight to e5 a knight in sconce in the
e5 square and black has completely shut
down white's demonstrations on the king
side he is an isolated knight on a4 does
white
definitely better for black in this
position
night on the rim is dim it's an old
chess expression that's still valid
after a hundred years
well wesley still is trying to argue
differently in his game right now he's
got a knight on a5 and i just love this
piece tonight i used to not care what
piece i had but now the knight is
certainly my favorite piece just it's
just clear it has all these magical
powers it looks like for humans to try
to understand and here comes this knight
onto d5 the answers are saying this
position is slightly better for white
but not by much so wesley would be happy
with the draw i think with the black
pieces here and
why is it only slightly better for white
there's lots of
pawn up afterwards
but after b5 here comes the bishop then
the rook to d8 that d6 pawn doesn't look
like it will stay too long but he has to
be careful about that wait wait this
move rook h8 at some point exactly
that's lurking so
a4
whoa a4
oh boy i'm not a big fan of the a4 move
uh maurice not with the king with with
so many pieces hovering around the king
i thought hikaru was going to get on his
pony and giddy up and get that knight
over
to c3 he hasn't played that he played a4
and then he's moved his rook into the
game via the h4 square
whoa what did uh wesley play in reaction
to a4 by the way oh you played king g7 i
see
and the engines think this position is
dead equal actually not it should be
seven really great chances here
absolutely
and
i just don't see how hikar is going to
hang on to his d6 pump yeah this one is
leaning towards a draw guys let's switch
back to the other game which is full of
fight
we see gary kasparov with a better
position here as black and the engines
like the idea of f6 right now this move
f6 blasting open the file the f-file
it's a very principled move if you're
going to give up this this
shield around your king
you know you might give black some some
white some chances and gary decided not
to do it with f6 instead he's playing
the move bishop to g4 still better for
him here this move bishop g4 black's
pieces are just great in the main
position this is the other game let's
get back to the gary game bishop to g4
on the board now attacking a rook
classic sicilian position
but this is the kind of sicilian
position you have where you as black you
feel like i'm comfortable thanks a lot
you have no real attack going now i just
need to make some moves and gary playing
directly now with the move rook fc8 also
a good line engines didn't think that
again was the best way to prosecute the
advantage in this position
but you can't complain black's position
looks
really good
white's attack looks like he's going
nowhere he is bishop on g2 what's that
piece about the measurement and f4 the
knight on a4 white's gonna have to be
careful b3 a solid move you got to watch
out for knight c4 that's the problem
but just a quick question why didn't he
just play bishop g4
uh bishop d7 earlier and just go after
the knight and capture that knight and
then stick a knight on c4 exactly that
does look like it would have been quite
promising you know the engines are
giving this unbelievable move right now
knight to c4 that's what i like as well
right now knight to c4 and if you take
go queen a4 no queen c4 just no really
just take back is what it's giving
because a2 is hanging and the knight
and he played queen a5 instead that's a
really crazy idea with knight c4 but
queen a5 is now on the board with the
idea of scenes that's right it's like
reinforcing it so smarter uh
simple human play what he just did
meantime this game is closing in on a
draw this one here queen to a5 a rich
position but gary's only problem he's
down a minute plus on the clock
that's right knight c4 looks like a big
time move coming up here by the way i
think a nice uh idea along with the
queen a5 is to just stop bishop takes e5
i can recapture with the queen in this
case and i think this move queen a
five is really annoying to fabiano
because he has to look out for the
bishop d7 and queen takes a2 i think
king b1 is box
what about this b5 and uh queen d4 h3
bishop h3 stopping the bishop d7 idea is
what the engines are giving but that's a
tricky move to find if he finds it it'll
be fanta wow look at that he found the
move
beautiful play by the u.s champion he
realized what the main danger was and
now he stopped kasparov's attack
what a great move to find in a situation
like this one you can't move the knight
by the way to c4 because of rook d5
always on the board so great play by
caruana
yeah i just did a couple of moves there
that gary i think really fitted away's
advantage by not playing that move
bishop d7 and no question about it uh
fabby's back in this game
and now h5 h5 trying to get his own game
going he's going to try and going to
play g6 nights
yes h5 was a mistake h5 he should have
taken the bishop on c4 now suddenly
knight c4 banged down on the board
because the bishop is guarding the d5
pawn by the way he couldn't just ignore
what was happening on the other side
black still had initiative h5 was a slip
and this is trouble for fabiano now he
has to play accurately or he will get in
trouble he's played the move rook to e2
and can gary do a crazy idea of like
knight eighth
on a very good day if he could go knight
a three to b-flat he's just taking on g5
just snapped off the pawn just snapped
it it's a free pawn
it's a pawn why not thank you very much
and again i just wanted to illustrate
that wouldn't that be a nice
dance with the pony
to get the knight to the c3 square and
then it's just checkmate to white's king
so there's that lurking strategic threat
of
dancing around with the prancing with
the with the knight
and fabi upon down
under pressure that's right he's gonna
need to find some way to get counter
play here but it's so tough because he's
rookie two now so it's so um
queen e5 is a huge threat
i hadn't realized just how strong that
threat was and he took the knight on c4
wrecking his queen side pawn structure i
cannot 35 is still possible bishop well
gary instead play bishop take c4 and
bishop and now bishop takes g5 queen
takes g5
check that's right oh this is
gary did not take back any pieces in
this position after you took on c4 he
didn't take on a4 he did not take on a4
so he is currently down a piece although
he has compensation according to the
engine which is very hard to see right
now he is still down a piece in this
position right now the engines give b3
as the best move let's fast forward to
the current position yes and he has to
play b3
whoa
he's forgotten his rook is look his name
is hanging out yeah
his rook is hanging he's made us give
this gary kasparov
and uh
he didn't chase it he didn't take it he
didn't take it no he probably thought
that afterwards takes c2 it's over takes
e2 oh my goodness it's over now he's
busted his car
if gary finds all the moves though he
has only 23 seconds bobby with only 14
seconds this is a disastrous turn for
and there it is
did find the right move there and now he
just has to giddy up and find mating
ideas there he goes they're blitzing now
oh my goodness the evaluation just
changing quickly as they're both in
serious time pressure but still gary's
collecting food on every move he's now
up a full exchange it looks like yeah
h5
there it goes as gary
wins the game that was not the most
accurate game of chess you'll ever see
but kasparov with the win keeping his
winning chances in the tournament alive
while fabi is just way out of it having
lost five out of six and let's see how
our tournament leader wesley soh is
faring against one of the greatest blitz
players in the world
hikaru nakamura upon up yeah wesley
mismanaged this position but but he
still has some drawing chances here
four rook endings are so difficult to
play and with so little time
yes he's got a half as much time as
nakamura yeah this is not going to be an
easy defense for him
somehow trying to trade off rook's
nakamura and establish a winning ending
if nakamura wins this game he will be
tied for first again with wesley so
there goes that c pawn and wesley not
coming up with a convincing way to
corral that pawn not at all no that's
right and now he's time
absolutely he's missed after king c5 he
had anticipated rook c one check but
there's rook c4 so this just didn't work
for for
uh wesley at all and this is resigned
to a little bridge built yeah well he's
just
rook d8 is about to come that's it there
it is that's it a beautiful game
and guess what guys
they're tied for first
time
it wasn't pretty it wasn't pretty the
way wesley handled himself it should
have been equal wesley had a great
position to solidify the game but you
know how naka is he starts putting
pressure on you and so a victory against
wesley so
the third game of this round that's
right third game of this round we're
done with our round robin done with the
round robin
now checking with tony rich so now once
again they started the day typhoon first
they're once again tied for first and
they're the clear leaders right now at
seven points each but gary kasparov with
that win
he's lurking he's lurking keeping
himself close while fabiano caruana
is saying his hopes are fading fast
gaining some distance here wesley so
nakamura remember when they came into
the round only half a point lead over
gary and one and a half over carolina
whereas now full point over gary and you
know caroline is going to have to win a
lot of games to get back into this
ultimate challenge absolutely jennifer
but guess what
six games to go we're going to take a
break and we're going to come back for
the
for the next round this is where
garrett's where exactly faces his
nemesis wesley so again will he be able
to overcome wesley finally as wesley has
had his measure in this round in this
whole tournament so far that's right
he's won three games against gary
at least right was it four or three it's
definitely three the two nights and then
the game today
yeah it's just an incredible
can you imagine wesley so winning so
many times against gary kasparov and no
luck this time no luck oh that was that
was brilliant i think that makes up for
the other two and we will be right back
with more from the ultimate blitz
challenge
[Music]
mike matheny manager of the cardinals in
chess fanatic at the world renowned
chess club and scholastic center of st
louis across from the world chess hall
of fame st louis status as the chess
capital of the nation is on full display
with a welcoming environment and
scholastic outreach program that works
with over 100 schools our goal is to
teach play and promote the sport so
whether you've played for years or never
before we invite you to experience all
chess has to offer
[Music]
[Music]
you could fly to venice
[Music]
or paris
or even copenhagen
you could fly all over the world
but why
when you could just come
to saint louis
your trip begins at
dot
explorestlouis.com
[Music]
[Music]
hey and we're back at the st louis chess
club for the next quad here in the
ultimate blitz challenge now this time
gary kasparov getting white against
wesley so wesley so having
played a marvelous blitz scam
best blitzcam
yeah i feel like a kid in the candy
store just my eyes are so big watching
these great players do their thing it's
just been fantastic as proud as gary was
of his game against wesley round one
yesterday he'd be even prouder if he
played the game that wesley defeated him
today that was really amazing he's got
revenge on his mind as this player seems
to be knocking him off since that early
victory game after game after game the
first two were blunders but last game
there were no blunders it was just
spectacular chess starting with that
gorgeous before now remember when gary
was white against wesley last time he
played a dazzling game it was a sicilian
where he played that b3 line that was
the line where he got his knight on c8
and d6 and blundered unfortunately to
ruin it
but this time he hasn't played the
sicilian it looks like he's going to go
for a catalan ready
uh style of play by gary kasparov and
he's done at b3 so strange that he's
choosing wesley as the one opponent that
he's straying from theory against you
know against nakamura and fabi he's kind
of staying with theory but in this game
and the first one he played against
wesley today playing some more obscure
openings and the double fee and kettle
he played with g3 and now the move d4 by
wesley d4 that's a serious move d4
having already played the move e6 you'll
have to support this pawn on c4 but he's
played knight to i mean on on d4 he's
played knight to c6 and black is down a
tempo in this line
by playing the move e6 and then e5 but
wesley insisting that it won't be a
problem for him he's now played bishop
to c5 he's looking to castle quickly can
white take advantage of this move order
yeah well it's a great bononi position
and i thought that would be the only way
what he just did with b4 this move
because if you capture with the bishop
the knight takes on e5 is in tap
bishop takes allows knight takes
we will probably see it though it
doesn't seem as well he can also play
knight takes now and just allow knight
takes but white will have chan will have
traded off his b pawn for the e pawn
that's the cause of the tempo in this
position and wesley now pausing as b4 is
on the board what to do about this
particular move and he's played knight
takes acquiescing to the fact that his e
pawn had to go
that's a good trade for white that's
right you never want to give up
on further flank pond especially the
b-pawn by the way b4 has been the move
of the ultimate blitz so far remember
when nakamura played it in a position
where he otherwise would have been
getting uh
smashed by gary um really nice b4 move
yeah yeah
and uh of course wesley and now again
another before look at this positional
move because sparrow played he played a3
very nice move sending the knight off to
the side of the board
that night just completely out of play
right now so the question is how does
kasparov take advantage of this
situation
and he's brought his knight down to the
night over to the
d2 square and after rook d8 just
dropping his knight back and he feels
pretty good about this particular
position as white it's benco style
compensation and that d-pawn it's going
to need some help without question that
was why
it was so costly for black's position
that he gave up the e that the loss of
the e5 pawn means that the spawn on d4
is a perpetual weakness and look at that
move by wesley
bishop d6 he had realized he's a pawn on
c5 he realized that he had to play the
move c5 and he made room but
does this give
you quite an opportunity i know i'm
thinking that white should take general
bishop
e5
wait wait
oh sorry c5 again i was thinking i was i
wanted to trade i wanted you to trade on
d4 but c5 i apologize so instead knight
takes d4 is not
a good
gary changing the character of the game
if we can refresh the board to the
current position he played the move
knight to b3 as we see this other game
is
looking droish even though it looks like
a complex position but it's looking like
he's going towards a draw and now a real
a real benoni
type position on our hands
as kasparov has all these pieces
developed the position right now is
coming down to the knight on a6 correct
black will have to make a couple of
moves to get this piece back into the
game
one bad piece in chess can cost you just
one bad piece especially at this level
so even though he'll be able to develop
his bishop off of c8 he'll be able to
get his rook into the game
and he has this d three pawn to look at
but that knight on a6 is gonna have to
solve itself and it's not so easy to
play knight back to b8 and knight to c6
with your c pawn hanging so
right now
wesley
in a little bit of difficulty especially
given that his whites move
in this position but how can white press
him that's the trick it looks like d4 or
something to break open the position is
natural but it allows the knight to get
to the c5 square and so gary is
hesitating on this move
he wants to play and he's played bishop
to g5 instead bishop to g5 chasing the
knight on f6 a good defensive piece uh
protecting black's king bishop g5
trying to make uh wesley's
life a little bit awkward by misplacing
the knight on f6 and uh
just um set back to d7 right just to
over protect also that pawn on uh on d4
on c5 and now before by gary kasparov
opening up the position that's right
because now if you take on d4 not only
will we have the b5 square but we'd also
have the f5 square so instead wesley not
capturing on on d4 but playing knight to
b6 attacking the c2 pawn i mean the c4
pawn rather
and uh trying to hold us off from from
playing d5 to get that big pawn center
no it's looking like a grunfeld
and openings are just morphing into each
other but he's taking on c5 and change
the character of the game yet again
allowing this knight wow to come into
the c5 square but we could play knight
d4 here well the engines decry this
exchange absolutely
go after trading off everything there
black is perfectly fine
that was not his greatest moment gary
kasparov having weakened his apon c pawn
all wesley needs now are just a couple
of accurate moves and he'll be
completely equal the engine's saying
queen d8 being the best move right now
queen d7 queen d7
yeah yeah these these ones all look
reasonable it is very good which one did
wesley choose it looks like he did
choose queen d8 and uh gary of winning
the queen trade with queen to c2 and
protecting his pawn on c4
knight ideas were in the position so h6
came like a shot by wesley that's why
you're kind of like queen d7
because we got we would get this
position and when this rook develops
itself naturally yeah but look at the
why he put it on the move queen to
f6 and now
because you can't take twice on e5
because we've got rook d8 check and
suddenly that queen on uh c2 comes into
play although you do have bishop f8 so
how's that variation shake out yes
so it's possible
he's got two pieces for the rook and now
rook has to play check i mean it looks
like there'll be no other no advantage
no he's played rook
to d1 after that move rook to d1 so he's
taken twice on e5 and then instead of
working hx starting with the rook e1
but now after but now after queen s6
well then i go then check and bring the
the other rock exactly because we don't
have time to take on f2 because we're
doing everything with chat no this right
now is critical he must play bishop f5
this was his only move to go into this
line and unbelievably he's just fine
after all the pyrotechnics the move
bishop f5 queen of six was not played
bishop f5 was playing wesley's found
every single tactical idea here to
equalize the position and he just every
single move
razor sharp all those moves and now he's
up upon temporarily
all those trades just brilliant defense
by wesley so giving away the pawn of
course and now an equal position maybe
slightly better for white after this
trade because he has the bishop but not
much to write home about as long as
black doesn't drop the a pawn in any way
and well of course after this will work
d7 that sequence was fantastic oh well
bishop e5 was a great move if you don't
see bishop f5 because i can't put my
queen on f5 because then you just have
uh rook v8 check and bishop b4 exactly
so um if we can go back we can see why
it's absolutely necessary we'll take a
look at that
later bishop to asia
i'm afraid if i go back
i'll automatically update my board and
i'll be in a conflict with the game as
it's ongoing with the analysis but
meanwhile now that we we have a pawnee
equality here what's going on in the
other game can we take a quick look at
nakamura versus caruana also a crucial
game and
hicaro to keep pace with this
extraordinary play by wesley soh is
going to have to beat the tail ender and
u.s champion
and number two in the world fabianic
ariana and
no because uh wesley is probably not
going to win so by drawing well i'm just
saying you know
to win himself and to keep pace uh queen
e67
uh with his threat to the e6 pawn
black under pressure rook
f6 under big pressure don't even
g5 here the engines did not like that
move at all believe it or not king f7
was the move being given bishop to e5
and white is better for sure you have to
put the rook on 8-6 to defend the pawn
but that rook is just relegated to being
a protector or defender only with no
attacking chances whatsoever so nakamura
is not going to be happy with that
choice
i'm sorry fabiano is not going to be
happy with that choice so fabi in a bit
of trouble right now
a bit of trouble a big big factor
um
trying to get rid of that queen
which is harassing
and the question
then after now i'm a little worried that
after queen a4 when you move your rook
we have like bishop d4 and you're over
extended no i guess you still have queen
c7 i have queen a3 also in the position
jen queen takes a yeah yeah is that true
i was actually looking at the sacrifice
in that position of queen takes a3 no
but look at this bishop g4 is powerful
because the rook on
b on d8 and the knight on a5 are going
to be hanging
and gary did draw his game as we
expected
now the move knight to c4
that queen g4 move was not accurate by
white queen g4 was not accurate knight
c4 has brought him back into the game
and he's looking to try to get some kind
of edge here he dropped his bishop back
to d4 but now
a3 could be taken
but it's instead
what did he allow he just allowed this
sequence with the queen to h5 and
suddenly black is in trouble because if
you play g6 we have bishop takes g6 and
then after pawn g6 there's actually just
queen h8 mate rather than queen g6 king
of that
position
he's terrible and queen g6 is a globe
and he's played it queen g6 big trouble
right now
bishop
now he just has to trade this off and
penetrate with his queen but he's trying
to work out a win fabiano with only 15
seconds left
naca has to find just a few quick moves
i think rook takes b3
opening up the b file so you can go
check check check and put your rook on
b7 with check well might not take on f6
first just so that uh the king is forced
to go to oh oh yes without question
and he's finally taken on b3 bishop
takes on e5 and it doesn't look like
it's mate anywhere so is well he's got
to be careful but is this move knight d2
a move
then there's then then it's all checks
and there's a rookie seventeen eight
seven and a quarter
what
he has dropped the exchange on f1 why he
played bishop g6 but it doesn't work
this right now the game is crazy
black according to the engine's
completely winning queen h2
queen h2 instead of bringing his knight
back out that was
enough but now the engines are given
look what he did he blundered again
did caruana and hung his queen to this
tactic he was completely winning at the
end but he just could not do it with the
time pressure caruana has now lost six
out of seven games wow six out of seven
games incredible back here there's an
issue here that the king actually was
escaping after rook b7 let's go this
position
this was this was winning here king f8
right now this is fine for him
he played bishop to g6 this was a
blunder and now the engine just said
just take your knight back out if you
bring your knight out it's easy there's
nothing there's nothing for white to do
here because you just don't win anything
you just knight back out and the rook's
not doing anything it's just a complete
win for him instead he took on h2 with
check
now the king took on f1 and now the
engines give rook to b8 as the best move
which is a bit of a surprise rook b8
there might be some tactics down here
but instead he played queen f4 which was
just a blunder after the trade and rook
to f3 and he lost the game caruana not
playing quickly enough and
just making mistakes
he's not showing any fine form in blitz
right now he's lost six out of seven he
was the last three yesterday and three
out of four today and in this game
he's just out of it in this game of gary
kasparov you got to give wesley so
incredible credit for finding this
bishop f5 this is the only move this
move bishop f5
what gary when gary went into this whole
combination this forcing combination he
had envisioned this opportunity for
himself of simply winning
thanks to these back rank issues that
black has we'd be forced to play
something like bishop e6 and and give up
an exchange and be in between
yeah
yeah
yeah
so that was why
this whole forcing sequel
it looks great every single move look at
this perfect
everything and he saved the game
incredible they were tied for first
so that's the situation so now ikaru
with the win
big win big one isn't he in first place
if we could draw that graphic i think
they were tied going into this round
weren't they so icaru with the win
is now clearly in first with eight
points
wesley at seven and a half gary's still
in the months with six and a half trying
to win today
but
well he did win one game today
gary but against fabi bobby is the
victim today he's losing a lot of games
he's at four points he's got to somehow
stop the bleeding as they're taking it
to him the rest of the field right now
but it is icaru nakamura the free
tournament favorite on paper who is
ahead in the competition right now
and gary again is in a must-win
situation having the black pieces
against ikaro nakamura because he cannot
let allow his
this man
to run away from the field and it's
going to be another group well not
another runefield i thought it would be
a greenfield but instead it looks like
it's um naka is stuck with the f3
but he's played gary's played a bemoni
type system exactly
and remember in their in their game
yesterday it was that crazy bononi game
that karu
was completely winning then gary had
turned the tables and he was completely
winning
and they're repeating their line of
yesterday which was a very very exciting
contest indeed we do see that a lot in
blitz right yes yes both players
stubbornly playing those their favorite
openings against one another
h5 by gary and the same idea that gary
had yesterday oh but the deviation
a novel idea gary had prepared for this
game knight h5 remember bobby fischer's
knight h5 from allowing bishop to take
stage five we've actually got t-shirts
and shirts over at cue boutique that say
night that's all it says of all the
moves of all the moves that you could
pick that is this doesn't matter in this
position because the rook is sitting on
h8 so you know by the way this is a
benoni player's dream of establishing a
bishop on e5 followed by putting the
knight on f4 followed by putting the
pawn on g5 big strategical decision
right here and now white must play
according to the engine white had to
play the move g4
in that position allowing the pawn takes
on passant and takes on poisson
and gary kasparov sensing opportunity
here f5 is a big move now pushed upon
from f7 to f5 play ala benoni style wild
play with the idea of playing the pawn
to f4 dominating all the dark squares on
the board that would just be a
tremendous move but very committal with
your king still sitting on the e8 square
not an easy move to make it
that means five he's not afraid he's
decided he's got to take it to him he's
gonna win this game quickly ripping it
off and playing knight d2 he figures hey
if two pieces want to go to e3
then maybe it's time to open up the
position a little bit wait a minute
great it's a lot of time to play queenie
seven here seven was the best move yes
you called it queen e7 was great but
instead he's played knight to e5 instead
maybe we can stick in a little queen c2
try to get a little playing so you've
got to watch the g6 square yeah but
that's why
that's why queen e7 was so good
attacking the bishop on e3 exactly but
knight now just losing a tempo or not
gaining a tempo now night now the
critical move yet again a move f4 is
hypercritical in this position but the
knight will go to g4
that unfortunately there it allows the
white knights to get the e4 square
potential access but it's a real
decision it looks like he has to make
this decision because gary himself wants
to play f4
and just get complete a complete bind
and he's done it these guys recognize
strategic concepts so quickly when they
have to do it you think they're just
tacticians no no no no they can't let
you get away with stuff and they
definitely spotted it now this night's
night
very unexpected
h5 in between so he has no time to play
knight takes e3 right and gary quickly
uh pardon me yes gary quickly
anticipating this move knight c4 and now
and now we're resuming the threat of
well the positional idea of playing they
take c3 since bishop takes h5 no longer
comes with shaq and look at this
oh hikaru giving up the dark square
bishop again a binoni player's dream 93
93 bishop d4 right
maybe he's just thinking they're in that
position bishop h5 and then after bishop
takes e3 check king h1 so perhaps gary
trade off yeah yes that's exactly what
is is possible i think gary wants to
keep everything on the board in this
position he wants to play something like
queen to e7 and build the game
what's amazing about this position where
i say it's 18 moves and how many 18
moves in less than four minutes how many
rich ideas have we seen so far
it's unbelievable
how much content have we been talking
about in less than four minutes by the
way what about knight g3 guys knight d3
happened knight g3 is that we've had it
all
we've got knight d3 on the board guys oh
shoot that is a big move the engines are
saying not good for black
accepted the challenge so are queens
coming to h4 that's the idea what's
amazing is the engines thought this was
good for white clearly good for white
but more analysis is showing that black
does have some compensation absolutely
after taking he has not captured yet
though he has not captured yet the idea
is that white can try to round up the
pawn with the
wait it's our move if we play rook f3
you just play queen h4 we're too slow
we do have this uh backward move bishop
g1
and we now have the capture and now the
knights and m4 a double capture sorry i
i did it wrong my my bad i had to
refresh myself so we've got a double
capture on g4 and now 94 was a mistake
94 was not the best move queen h4n
automatically
note that pawn on d6 will hang later so
queenie won forcing a trade and gary's
initiative has now died down completely
what defense that's the great thing
about nakamura he is such a great
defensive blitz player that's he can
just instantly assess what he needs to
do and he said let me get rid of all the
issues now just trading down and his
knight on c4 is a monster the pawn on d6
is awful that's right because if you
play a move defending it we can uh amp
up the pressure nobody's nobody's
defending anything
i agree
be serious gary's going to play bishop
f5 knight takes d6 bishop d3 if you move
your rook to f2 gary's going to play c4
and he's going to try to get some
compensation for his lost material good
yes
whether it's enough i don't know but
gary looks just hard can't get passive
here yeah gary looks disheartening
like knight d3 knight d3 you're thinking
nike i mean knight g3 excuse me if you
play a move like knight to g3 back here
you're thinking attack crush
mating variations and then the guy plays
this sequence with takes on g3 then
takes back and then trade again and then
put the knight in kill the pawn trade
queens sorry your attack is gone and he
has not moved yet and gary disarton
realizing he has to defend
a worse ending
he does have enough comp but it's not
the position he was looking for when he
dropped the knight on g3 and look at his
clock he's
scratching his head right now and he's
not pleased with the current state of
the variations he's not developed with
his pieces he's got to reset time to
reset i think i think there's an
exchange sacrifice in the position
gary's going to have to play rook d8
instead and after knight b6 and only now
play the move bishop f5 except the loss
of the rook but his two bishops will
keep the e file close and there's a pawn
on b2 some counter play with b5 what is
he saying with bishop d7 a pretty
stunning
option for him just going passive giving
away the d-pawn all right i just
refreshed my board so bear with me
uh but bishop d7 was gary's choice
probably hoping to get something get
some counter play going on the a4 pawn
if he can hit that knight and
and remove it but
and there's this pawn on b2 hanging too
and he has taken on a4
he did
but bishop c5 is on the board why can't
you just take the pawn
now with threats to take bishop c5
bishop b3
knight b7 rook f7 good chances there
they are knight d6 gary i don't know
there it is the pawn is now off the
board no this is tough this is tough
what is he down one clear pawn right now
and he's played the move
he's at b6
b6 on the board
that allows a capture of course that
allows the capture you can take that
pawn and now allow a rook to be eight
but he didn't take it he backed away and
played bishop to a3 defending b2 just
trying to keep the position under
construction d4 check that seems kind of
annoying
um but
real annoying would be to get that pawn
to g3 and then play bishop to d4 check
jet then you got checkmates down the
h-file but he's played bishop exactly
the move i liked
removed that pawn from the end nakamura
ideas and the fun
questions
he's attacked long before
the lord
he's alert to the dangers he's an
incredible defender in blitz that's why
it's so hard to take him down remember
that game fabi had when he was down a
rook for a queen and he managed to
somehow save that one miraculously and
he's just a tenacious defender and gary
has to find moves with his seconds
ticking down he's down to 27 seconds and
b5 and b look at nakamura's clock
advantage if he can find just two or
three moves right now he could really
cause trouble for gary gary cannot
hesitate it's time to make some quick
moves as that delay is not helping him
as he stops to think
five seconds past six seconds past
before he finally made a bishop on a2
wow just burying the bishop to get rid
of uh to get out of any uh discoveries
by hikaru but check it out i'm gonna try
to play the move a5 since you can't take
on b5 because in bishop c4 and then
we're also trying to move um b4 trapping
the bishop and the pawn now drop and
there's the threat now b4 is a threat
after rook to b8 and bishop back out to
c5
with gary downs only 19 seconds he
played b4
white has to make progress somehow but
look at him consolidate his position
first rook to d2 a5 looking for a past
pawn absolutely
brilliant
great defense by gary as well
yeah but will he be able to do it in
time he has a real issue here and b3
whoa
buried forever on a2 i don't like that
and that was sacrifice look at kasparov
what did he do he sacrificed on f4
rook takes whoa
he's changed the whole tenor of the game
and now
is back in the hunt tactic now looking
to trade off the dark square bishop he
understands he can't whoa
he the only trouble he has is his bishop
is out the game and that knight and rook
are trying to combine to mate him but
he's figured out he won bishop
there it is
back gary is
back in safety mode and his king is
stalemated for the moment but
trying to weave checkmating uh net with
the knight on f6 and the rook on the
seventh round and gary's aware that
there's no mate and look at him he's
bouncing bobbing and bobbing and weaving
he's like give me that pawn now he has a
passport on himself so that's dangerous
how does he untangle those pieces he now
is looking to get his king out
ready to go to e6
very good
and the other game was a draw the other
game ended in a draw incredibly with
only 15 seconds gary realizes he can
save this position once his king is out
his bishop can always sacrifice for the
g pawn so exactly now he's perfectly
fine
he might start even looking to do
something he just he just attacked the
knight but we can always can't we can we
simplify here if we really want to yes
he just takes on b3 rook takes g5
any time he wants the two players can
draw nakamura shaking his head he got
outplayed he looked over to see what
happened in the other game and he
realized something went amiss as gary
defended
like the rocker gibraltar amazing chess
by kasparov to save the game and that
game ended in the draw as well wait a
minute what do you mean amazing chess by
kasparov amazing chess by nakamura as
well well he has a big edge well come on
when somebody spanks down knight g3
sacrificing
the king
what he'd do instantly
by the way that's very instructive guys
knight to e4 so that you can play knight
g3 and then force the trade of queens
with queen ewan and we saw that same
kind of idea in wesley's game where he
played queen f8
stopping the attack yeah again this
looks like a fearsome fearsome attack
that
nakamura's king was under and the way he
just neutralized that whole attack was
poetry this was incredibly well played
i think he was shaking his head because
he had the minute and 40 seconds against
about 15 seconds on the clock he saw
that situation was a big edge for him
and all he had to somehow do was keep
the game under control but kasparov hit
him with that move rook takes f4 and
then bishop 86 bishop d2 something naca
is used to doing to people
but gary showed that he can defend as
well and he had his bull face on like no
i'm not going down and he's still within
the possibility of catching nakamura he
would have liked to win that game but
that's what it is he's for this four
rounds to go nakamura with still only a
half a point lead over wesley so gary
kasparov a full point behind wesley at
seven caruana definitely out of this
competition now even if he won the next
four games somehow
naka would only be tied with nakamura
right so there's no way in the world all
the math is going to work in fabi's
flavor essentially he's been
mathematically eliminated
from first
and knockout
you know he wrote this article on
chess.com about bullet tips one of the
big tips was never resign another one
was if you're in a zone and you're
winning games you're playing great
keep playing yeah press your luck
that's right it's not luck it's more of
like that zone flow state right yeah
yeah exactly but who's in zone and flow
right here probably wesley
these men wesley and nakamura have
given as a great treat did you see
wesley wesley trying to talk to nakamura
there just before say he said something
to tanaka naka just looked up at him
like who are you talking to
let's play chess well wesley's so good
proof that you can be super nice and
still brutal on the board right yeah we
saw that in the first game
and wesley um opening with knight f3 and
we're seeing uh looks like we're just
going to see a queen's gamba decline
that's the first time we've seen this
opening in blitz this is the game of the
round these are two players only half a
point separate them and if wesley wins
this game he takes the lead in the
tournament exactly
leapfrogging so this is a huge game the
last last game of this round
wesley definitely wants this point like
without question because he's gonna this
is probably his last white against
nakamura as well so he wants this point
but they seem to be revisiting the line
they played earlier in the tournament
they played the same line yesterday
exact same line right i remember uh
vish vishy anand winning a key game in
his world championship match
against
magnus carlson with the breakthrough
b4b5 followed by
c5 c6 which is why
uh icarus played this move queen c8
stopping that tactic
and quickly queen c2 and queen b7
all theories so far
that's why they're playing so quickly we
see rook b1 by wesley giving away the a
file if naca wants to grab it with
taking on b4
and if uh nakamura says that this game
isn't important to him he's lying
he's
he's the man here in the us and blitz
and he wants to show especially somebody
like wesley and bobby that
as well as the world yeah
he did trade on the a file and now
played the move rook to a3 cementing his
rook in wise position he can always
bring his other rook over to a8 this
position is looking pretty tepid at the
moment
white not having any clear breaks to
show advantage or play anywhere
there is poison in the position of
maurice
the usual strategy for white is to play
rook c rook fc one bring the knight back
to e1 bring the knight to d3 often times
the b-pawns get traded and the knight
stands beautifully placed on the b4
square attacking the c6 pawn but icaru
has a great deal of experience in this
particular line on both sides of the
board and body language should also
speak about this position because you
can't just lean back it is sure look at
the car arms folded like make a move
i'll come when you're ready and he's
come back into an intense focus on the
board but he knows he's played this line
to essential equality more or less
and his other rook now hesitating in
this position he's going to bring his
work to the a file and the idea you
mentioned yes 91 now
being played on the board tonight
retreating headed to the d3 square very
nice play by wesley and
black has to be careful because this
move b4 b5 hangs over his head
uh well b5 has actually just been played
by nakamura and hence that's why we see
ikaru playing the move himself just to
shut down that uh tactic queen b2 by
wesley attempting to perhaps seize the a
file
but that will lead
too far
he
queen b2 doesn't fit with the strat
white's basic strategy with the queen
side now closed
usually white plays knight d3 f3 and e4
i think that this is going to be easy
equality not what and knight e4 yes 84
best move actually according to the
engine because of course you've given up
control with the smoke queen's queen
queen b2 really a little bit of a
mistake so if we play knight e4 and just
attack the pawn you simply have a move
f5
as well as knight f6 and the d5 square
will fall inside black's hands
that's just great compensation now
wesley not happy with this position
this would be tremendous if nakamura won
this game he'll take a point and a half
lead
on wesley
and i guess
yes and also gary even if gary won the
other game
which is right in the opening right now
and the trade has happened because if
you don't then knight c3 and rook a2 and
black's starting to um infiltrate
himself
yeah let me just
take a quick peek at gary's game is that
incredibly still just in the opening
still very slowly
e3 we'll go back to our uh
fight for first place and now there's a
fight for the a file
what is the knight doing on c2 this
night is going to be gorgeous this is
just good for black
very very good and wesley so with that
one slip queen two in a trade and almost
hoping for maybe b takes a four but even
though you'd have a past pawn that would
let wesley's knight get back into the
game with knight a3 and knight c4 so
guys um
slowly looking for an edge is nakamura
but the key in this position is the
position so blocked yeah it's so blocked
it's very hard even to find a sequence
that allows this bishop on e7 as now
king f1 has been played allows this
bishop on e7 to get into the game knight
to d5 attacking the bishop and now the
bishop is going to move it's going to e5
how does black make progress against
this fortress position that white has
created now f6
he would love to break the position
somehow but how does he make any real
progress after the bishop is dropped
back to the g3 square it looks as though
this is just drawn it doesn't seem as
though there's defense any way to make
real progress here lots of time on the
clock
what just happened he just he had this
move night before because if knight
takes b4 there's queen d1
if you were queen c2 wow
hello no fortress no fortress the king
on f1 was a mistake the king on f1 he's
just shown it that king marching over to
the f1 square by putting it there he set
up his own
self mate
and now he's busted
now nakamura just stole this pawn with
his tactic and
we should go back just one second just
to show the audience right here
you cannot take with the knight
you can't take her the night because of
queen to d1 mate and by the way that was
the key the king going to f1 and
nakamura spotted the tactic and that
changed the whole evaluation of the
position that's right and he could have
played at the move before but no reason
not to throw an s6 because there's once
once you play f6 it's not even if leslie
saw it at that moment there's nothing he
can do about it
a huge tactic
he's so alert tactically he'll win this
game he'll take over complete command of
the tournament just play queen a2
dominate the white queen so there's no
counter play with queen a5 and checks
and stuff queen a2 dominate
the game and with pawn in hand icaru is
going to just cruise to victory in this
game so let's take a look at gary's game
then because it looks like nakamura wow
he found that nice tactic in a simple
game position just goes to show you just
because there's not a lot of pieces left
on the board doesn't mean there's no
tactics exactly he's so gifted though he
was incredible he spotted that one and
we had we do have a scotch uh gary came
uh
well prepared that does he have an
advantage it's hard to see why well
ariana just played a big move here just
played the move f5
um he's going to understand no time for
ambassador because that e3 knight is
hanging right and gary's bishop dropped
back to e2
and was threatening bishop c4 so we saw
this move king g8h8 getting out of that
uh
bishop and notice our nice pressure here
fabiano's pressure on the the g2 square
he's got a knight and the bishop bearing
down on that but if we if and if we try
to play the move g3 the problem is now
we're gonna come in with queen c6 and if
you take our knight we have checkmate
and you wouldn't have time to play
bishop f3 anymore because not enough
pieces defending that square you know
we're doing all this analysis and all i
can see is the clock
gary has wish you a minute less 42
seconds left by the way the only clock
just so that there's some no confusion
the only clock that really counts is the
clock next to the player so pay
attention to that clock only sometimes
you might see a little bit of refreshing
going on on the digital cl on the 2d
board that's not accurate the only
accurate clock is that one you see there
and that one is keeping time perfectly
for the game gary now down to 41 seconds
2 10 and you see there that it's not
exactly right it's constantly refreshing
here on the 2d board
in the meantime
black is happy oh he just he just
shifted his queen to g6 putting
additional pressure on the g2 pawn what
um jennifer was mentioning and there was
no way g2 g3 was going to be played so
gary had to bring his rook up to f2 and
this is this is the move d6 that i
thought uh was as a key issue for white
now rook d8 is almost an automatic he's
playing what happened and now gary's
playing d7
not as much to try to save the pawn but
is to leave the the rook at bay exactly
nakamura prosecuting his advantage quite
well if you want to jump to that
position just quickly nakamura managed
to trade off queens and now he has a
real advantage
in this position
and wesley trying to defend that a pawn
is galloping down the border but weight
shift d4 bishop d4 on the board
bishop before it looks nice look at that
that's beautiful there it is a winning
move
gorgeous play forcing resignation as the
a pawn will queen
nakamura taking control of the
tournament with that win
beautiful fight buddy like finish there
a2 would have allowed wesley the tempo
he needs to be able to play and cover
the a1 square so that was why this final
move bishop d4 so sweet after king takes
a2
your bishop can't get not
with only three games left nakamura just
amazing tactics we saw the night before
we saw the bishop to d4
and
meantime look at gary
in trouble
with only 13 seconds left very very
unhappy with the turn of events
happening here and with the white pieces
yes
and a tail ender as well
bobby wants to win a couple of games
show that he's a player as well but come
on only 13 seconds
now
11 seconds left for gary we've got
rookie seven night after look at knight
d6 oh this is a beautiful beautiful
strategic mastery by fabiano in this
game as that's right he's taking it to
gary running we were just running 94
winning in exchange um so bishop d3 was
was forced and then we played bishop to
e4
oh this is a beautiful dominating game
more exchanges another night
on e4 gary desperate looking for moves
over guys but the problem is you can't
move the rook away because we've got
knight after each act exactly so again
there's a sacrifice expertly desperate
with 95 here
it was a sacrifice knight g3 on the
board but not but caruana missed it and
now gary hesitating there he's got three
seconds on his clock three seconds to
play the entire defense he is in huge
trouble right now
what will happen will
karwana figure out exactly what to do he
just needs to make a couple of he
doesn't even need to do anything right
around now just make some moves and he's
played this
trade on f2
and then and then takes an e8 but
luckily
he's in exchange an exchange up
winning position
yeah on the board winning on the clock
and
has to move he has to move and his time
is down to two seconds only
two seconds
i mean it would take a miracle to save
this position
gary has received
miracles that's right gary has gone down
in that game nice display by fobby
fabulous beautiful play you don't see
that happening to gary kasparov very
often wow and let's see how does this
all change the standings nakamura
cementing his lead owning the day is
nakamura right now nakamura just playing
you saw him when he came in he sat down
first everybody else
was walking around he said it's time to
get down to business yesterday you saw
him all smiles a lot of gagging yeah you
know it's not that serious yeah right
today the game faces on and one of the
greatest blitz players on the planet is
showing it right now demonstrating his
tactical
awareness just lightning quick when it
comes to your blunders he will find it
in a second
and his defensive skills especially and
look at this score he's running up the
score guys nine and a half points wesley
so at eight points gary at seven fabiano
mathematically knocked out at five and a
half and it would take a miracle for
kasparov to win this tournament right
now
it would be a complete collapse by
hikaru for gary to win i think it's
merely
well not mathematically
yeah but it's very unlikely so nakamura
is showing his stuff today
the difference between today and
yesterday yesterday he was defending
well but
wasn't so sharp otherwise today it's the
complete package right he's playing well
in his openings and middle games endings
as well as you know keeping his mistakes
to a small minimum and
wow tactically
she's the man when it comes to blitz we
do have three games left for you well
rather three rounds left for you so six
games um not going to want to miss any
of that and you know on the community
day here in st louis we went to some of
the schools hundreds of schools that
were serving here at the st louis chess
club and fabiano and maurice went to a
school in ferguson
[Music]
we're playing a simula against these
kids at coke elementary they're awesome
[Music]
who thinks they can be me
[Music]
who thinks they can beat bobby
we got our hands full all right let's
get started
[Music]
it's a little competitive he talks trash
what are you doing with your rook
you want to whoop me in chest let's see
you learn how to play chess before you
say things like that well you better
practice because right now i'm coming to
get you
checked to that king
[Music]
i'm really excited to play three
messages you gonna say chicken i'll be a
remove
nice move
i'm impressed by that move
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the ultimate
blitz challenge here in saint louis
hikaru nakamura which is three rounds to
go
looks very confident because
he has a point and a half lead and he's
got this tournament
if he just
you know goes through uh three draws
bam he's he he's got it but girls are
not very common
they're also not about to get some three
draws like that in blitz yeah that's
right remember fabiano carolina did beat
him in their challenge match
he needs point and a half
but we don't jump down your exactly
but um nakamura having played a very
well today and fabiana who has been the
tail ender just put together a master
class against gary kasparov has fabi got
what it takes to take down the leader
it's important when people are out of an
event what do they have to play for what
is his motivation now fabiano caruana
knowing that he has no chance anymore
all the pressure is off and we know
professional teams in sports they love
to play spoiler against the teams that
are trying to win championships or going
to the playoffs can fabi do the same can
he find that motivation to beat naca to
play spoiler right now
he does have the white pieces so he's
going to look to see if he can pull it
off and a loss by him of course wesley's
going to have to beat gary kasparov on
the other side to bridge the gap and
that's not going to be easy and gary's
in the same boat as well he's realizing
now he's realized already that his
chances of doing anything have simply
he's basically gone
he's basically playing for second place
and he's gonna have to try to
show something in the next set of games
he certainly doesn't want anybody like
fabi sneaking in and catching up to him
he's repeating the opening from the
immortal blitz game remember we have the
same word of which game by wesley in the
opening of today's round i i've been
having the
uh my board uh on the
hikaru game
but i'll switch it now over and a repeat
once again
of the
brilliant brilliant game and gary said
i don't believe you he's repeating that
it wouldn't exact same line let's do
this again let's dance
as gary
already figured out an antidote to this
incredible c5 pawn sacrifice that wesley
essayed earlier in the day well it
doesn't look as though he has because
he's hesitating right now as wesley has
repeated the exact same line
gary's
a very principal player if he doesn't
believe you he will play the same
variation
but right now and he has played the move
and they're in the exact same position
where
wesley in this position essayed
wait no the last time he played c5
didn't he in this position
yeah he's no he played h3 bishop d7 c5
h3 right that's correct now he's played
a different move allowing knight to f6
and now they're in the king's indian
proper except that bishop sitting on g4
and the white knight on d2
the two key changes in the position and
guess what c5 is back on the board yet
again
this c5 move is thematic as far as
wesley so is concerned and he's opened
up the c line very quickly without any
tempo losses chasing the bishop now at
h3 and pushing gary backwards and
where's that bishop going to go d7 but
that allows eventually to move knight to
c4 so he's preparing it as wesley so
with rook to e1 he didn't want to hang
his e pawn
you remember it wasn't so pretty for
gary in the last battle and he had a
knight sitting on c8 in order to defend
against knight c4 so he played the move
b5 no he did not believe
i i'm suggesting the move b5 because
everything marie said was right on the
button and that knight on c4 and he did
it yeah of course uh the knight on c4 is
going to be so powerful
that you just stop it you just have to
stop it that's all it comes down to and
wesley uh has just played the move
bishop e1 principal idea in the position
bishop f1 principal id in the position
for black as to get in the move f five
but gary knight recognizing that his
knight on e7 doesn't have the future has
played knight c8
in order to come to b6 and look at this
wesley playing beautiful both players
anticipating the plans of one another uh
wesley has played b3 so that when that
knight comes to b6 it doesn't have
either c4 or a4 as a outpost also you
have to look out for bishop a3 now
another way to target the pawn on d6
exact exactly by the way in the other
game
nakamura has gotten a bit of an edge
with the black pieces if he wins the
game he's virtually guaranteed winning
the tournament although mathematically
still would be up for grabs but very
rich position here
very complex position
when we do this when we do this next
time we're we're gonna have to stagger
these games instead of doing them
simultaneously because we want to see
both games of course they're fantastic
they're just incredible to watch all
these games of course it would take
longer for the broadcast but i think
that the fans would forgive us with such
thrilling games going on at the same
time i couldn't agree with you more
maurice each game should be showcased
these players are just phenomenal and
they're they're giving us a fantastic
treat
and they should be showcased so that
game still you know all to play for i
see three results as possible and let's
switch back to gary's game for a second
as the players have been
taking their time a4 and a6 have been
inserted into the position and now um
taking on b5
at some point you know we might be able
to make use of that a6 square to um get
some extra pressure on a d6 the problem
in this position for for white
is this knight on d2 with the pawn on b5
the knight doesn't seem to have a
natural square it's going to have to go
back to b1 and find the c3 square but in
the at the moment his center is just
suddenly under attack with this move f5
by kasparov and so this knight sitting
on d2 is a passive square so he's going
to be busy doing other things he's just
playing the move rook to a6
sounds
down and it'd be really sweet if we
could play 95 and hop into e6
unfortunately um
that square we're not it's not
accessible so we can't really uh do
anything with either of our knights here
so
um white's position looking powerful
except for the knight position i agreed
and this rook on on a6 is really
bothersome you'd really love to play the
move rook b6 here but you don't want to
walk into bishop
b4 to a5 which would pin the rook and
win in exchange
so uh
pressure for
wesley
and a beautiful move by gary
posting his bishop on h6 it's all about
activating your pieces and we can see
that this rook on a6 the bishop on b4
very very active bishop on g7 wasn't
doing much now has a better diagonal and
are we seeing an exchange in f5 and gary
has taken with a bishop on that square
oh with the bishop unexpectedly i don't
like that at all because of the e4
square right absolutely
maurice has been talking about what is
that knight on d2 going to do well if
you recapture with the bishop
go
with g4 and now he's gonna be ready to
play the knight into e4 a beautiful move
by wesley i really like how oh wesley is
playing great game and you see a little
shaken as gary brings his bishop back to
d7 perhaps not regretting not capturing
with the pawns
but now there's three
he had to capture with the pawn because
there was a tactic in the position with
the rook on a6 attacking the bishop all
the way across the board on eight oh
there's a sacrifice on e5 right there's
1985.
e5 so he actually tactically slept on
that one with his bishop on the 86th
square and that is why he took back with
the bishop instead of with the pawn and
is now strategically worse absolutely
absolutely and all of white's pieces
looking very very good that's right
forced to defend with the queen which
also creates another pin and uh
potential tactics in the position
although right now everything is held on
to here right i would love to be able to
play the move knight d for jumping into
the position but from the moment uh the
discoveries don't seem like they leave
anything and in the other game hikaru is
owning the board against fabiano caruana
flip to that board that pawn is on d6
but it looks completely insecure as he
just played b4 chasing the bishop
backwards and white hanging on for dear
life trying to keep that pawn on d6 but
he could capture it right now if he
wants to he can just take on e4 and then
rip off the pawn on d6
that trade bishop takes knight whatever
you take with most likely the bishop of
course and then queen takes pawn on d6
he would be up a pawn although white
would have a great light square bishop
and the two bishops as well but that's
still a pawn and ikaru is trying to
judge whether or not it's a smart idea
he is in a little bit of time pressure
well at least a deficit against fabiano
right now and he decided after all that
thought hey it's a pawn
he has decided to take the pawn he's now
ahead by one pawn
but he's gonna have to face these two
bishops
which by the way the bishop on c1 is not
really saying much exactly but i don't
think it's a fearsome uh pair of bishops
there maurice
no it does it certainly does not look
completely clear but queen h5
does ask a big question though right now
queen to h5 i guess g6 no g6 would would
stop anything from happening because the
knight can always drop back to the g7
point so that knight is ready to defend
well it's on the floor and g6 and g6 and
he backed up with queen f3 yeah
the sacrifice was would lead nowhere and
and therefore that was why queen f3 was
played putting pressure on this knight
on c6 while they're maneuvering wesley's
soul has broken through against casparo
that g6 pawn is now off the board
gary was not able to curtail the
position in any way and now he is in
trouble down a full pawn in the position
as wesley's hitting the bishop on d7 and
the pawn on g6 as well and ignoring the
bishop he's played f e4 e4 what
bishop position where he is hoping that
he has a drawing hand but wait a minute
what is up with bishop bishop d2 but we
have rookie seven here so uh he also has
rookie two just attacking the bishop
there it is yeah and now he's gotten a
pawn back
but he's down
one
on the board and he's got a d-pawn he's
got to deal with d6
next to
f3 gary barely holding on and playing
before
for his life here so now what do you do
after rook c7 he's going to have to drop
he's going to have to go into full
passive mode i'm afraid and he's played
your move rook c7 gen i think he's gonna
have to play rook on f three back to
oh he's playing b4 before and now
completely ignoring the d-pawn because
he's got a beep on himself that's right
so now if we play d
um instead king g2
it looks like uh leslie just played king
g2 at some point he's maybe going to
play f4 to create another bass bomb
but
this is good defense by black there's no
way to crash through and the b pawns on
the board so there's just
what kasparov is understood working why
do you cannot crash through this is the
key rookie true trying to double rooks
on the seventh there and and you notice
that if you play b3 and we play rookie
seven and you play b2 we actually had
just have made and do right exactly but
it's it's not it's not mate rook f6 will
control the position later
so he can go for it kasparov he has to
make a calculation really fast and
realize that he is defending with rook
to f6 at the right moment he should just
chase with his b pawn and instead he's
going after the deep on
so he just played work to d8 and we we
see rook e6 yeah the engines did not
like gary's defense at all
now he's just down material but his beep
one is accountability and does wesley
what is wesley's idea now so he's
knocked up a pawn he always has a this
drawing hand perpetual and perpetual
check in hand yes but he has a big edge
on the clock he's not going to try to
perpet this position
no way well
he has to find some way to stop the
b-pawn
but i don't but he can stop the b can't
you put a brook on b7 at some point and
maybe
rook c1
b2
rook b1
but in that case he should have his rook
he should play rook handle
you're asking him to go past it yes he
doesn't have time for rook g7 b2 rook b7
because we can uh just the queen in that
position
right and then i'm saying rook h6 king
g8
and then go passive with this rook he's
got three pawns versus one right yeah
that's his why can't he why can't he's
what is he's doing i don't understand
why he can't put his rook
why can't he put his rook to h7 and when
the pawn because then uh because then
you after rook b7 we can just queen
no what happens on rook h7 right rook h7
b2 b2
and
there is no mating idea with
then i play the rook c the g7 with check
and then when your king goes to f8 play
rook b7 okay and the king goes back to
g8
and i still got the beeping still
threatening to queen that's true right
that's a tricky line rook eight seven
doesn't
that doesn't make sense
exciting game yeah there's always
there's all those kinds of drawing
formations with the double work attacks
right right
oh quickly now in time pressure oh there
was a way to do it there was a way you
move your rook over to d7 in that
position the la the rook on the h file
he has to take the draw now and gary is
repeated well that one will look at he
did have a way to make his advantage
work but let's switch over to the leader
fabiano carwana against against the
leader of nakamura and nakamura has
fought back against those bishops and he
is perfectly okay but can he win in this
position now that wesley's drawn a win
for him would be virtually decisive in
the event caruana with only 8 seconds to
13 seconds seconds moves coming quickly
by the way the the game is beginning to
open up for the bishops but after this
move f5
uh ikaru
is going to be able to pick up the h6
pawn as well as the f5 part oh this
counter play on the green side there
goes one but there's a big line on the a
or
g4
oh my goodness this is going to be close
and those queen side those queen pawns
are very good against knights right
those outside past pawns but look at
that picking up a tempo to to reposition
his knight and why oh no white rubble
white maybe why
why why bishop e4 mission before was a
big mistake
losing a key tempo back on the defensive
end there it goes he's going to win the
bish well now he's just playing for a
draw
if he can get over there but it doesn't
look like it's going to happen the
knight's going to end up on f8 he's
going to play knight g6 knight f8 take
the a pawn that's going to be game he
resigns
in the position
wow nakamura that's an important
constellation that maurice mentions
because you know it wasn't for the fact
that that the pawn can move two squares
we could just stick our king on g7 right
exactly then h5 well nakamura with a
dominant situation by the way let's just
show that so the fans can see it right
here really fast two positions of
importance in this position
right here king to g5 knight back to f8
this was the key guarding this pawn no
matter what you do which is go after
your pawn here and now you realize you
can't touch the knight because this
h-pawn runs down the board so you have
to just sit king takes pawn and that
would have been it the other game by the
way and that's why he resigned the other
game this is the position
which could have happened here rook down
and if b2
rook check and rook to b7 this is what
we were analyzing a second ago the mate
is on the board here so you don't want
to trade rooks you lose this pawn and
have two pass pawns so the only move is
to come back to challenge this rook but
the key move to find is this one
and suddenly
black has no progress to make and both
sides are frozen actually white is
threatening rook takes here
the rook could move but now these pawns
start to go down the board as well so a
challenge in this position to even find
moves for black it seems as though he
was actually winning this position but
anyway it was wild
it's still wild in this position in
effect
so let's get back to the standings
themselves
that's right nakamura's got a massive
lead on the field now with two
two rounds to go so wesley has to win
both of his games and nakamura has to
lose both for wesley
right so now what we're talking about is
must win situations for wesley so
meanwhile um second place wide open but
nakamura just showing um he's he's the
blitz boss today he he's been he's been
in superb form
and that's the way it is with these guys
when somebody gets into the superb form
that they're capable of they can run
away with the tournament and they think
all four players have that capacity
capability but when hikaru does it
he just looks majestic i mean almost
untouchable in fact he's the end boss
when it comes to blitz wow
yeah
and he's had this reputation for
almost 15 years 10 years i mean when he
was young
he was he was a great blitz player just
as a preteen that's right and this game
of course is going to be quite
interesting we're going to keep our eyes
on gary kasparov verse and nakamura both
of them
love to pull faces that are perfect for
internet meme
well gary certainly would love to win
this game to just spoil
nakamura's party just a little bit of
course as they go into a scotch again
and by the way uh
gary
on the first day of his scotch was it
was achieving positions that he was
really in
mastering uh
now everybody is playing this variation
against his scotch
yeah they're all cop you're totally
right they're all copying hikaru because
the other line is like a little bit
trickier to play when you haven't
analyzed it more easy to play in blitz
exactly exactly
and this is just the adjustments that
the elite grab masters make and naka is
the expert of that what openings are
good to play in blitz what openings are
better to play in classical because he
has so much experience and he's such a
practical player absolutely and he's
willing to change the job we should
point out that wesley soh
is not doing anything in his game
against fabiano caruana he
basically has to win out but he has
simply simplified that game they're in
this queen's gambit
acceptance i think i've set up i think
wesley is acquiesced to the idea that
hikaru is uncatchable he just wants to
secure second place at this moment
knowing that his only rival for that
second place is gary kasparov who you
play
well when no he will he play him in the
last round
no he doesn't
know gary he just played gary and they
made it he will have to play karu with
black in the last round and it'll be
like a trot for hikaru
if if wesley plays him with no way of
catching him whatsoever but wesley's got
a hope that gary wins
as they play this position i think
wesley must be looking for a win though
in this game so we'll see what gary can
do to make any kind of headway
against knock but look at naka again
this is his posture when he is
comfortable he does not stay focused in
focus mode that is up alert over the
board when he feels like he's just okay
and he's just leaning back now arms
folded the is very content the neurons
are firing well the brains is working
perfectly and he knows this is the mode
he gets in when he wins game after game
after game against anybody
and nakamura just simply one of
the best blitz players
in the world
no question about it now a matchup we
would love to see no question magnus
magnus versus naca i think that would be
funny
magnus vs naca would certainly be a
great match i think people would pay to
see that one as i would pay to see that
oh man it's just fantastic you were told
that you could not watch that no i cried
how much do you want me to do that would
be a huge punishment actually that
should be our next bet
and let's take a look at who's in the
audience we've got our women's champion
nazi pakistan and number two somehow
she's made friends with hot devops
of course of course i'm joking they were
friends before but um not not an easy
situation with both of them playing for
the title and uh nazi leapfrogging
against her
um at the last moment but uh obviously
um in chess you know you gotta
that's that's the game you gotta play
make friends with your rivals and play
against them at some point absolutely uh
interesting move queen d2
by uh
gary kasparov here he had both pawns
hanging in the center i thought
um that he was going to play queen c5
actually
posting up on the c5 square but queen d2
inviting a capture of this e4 pawn and
i'm sure
hikaru nakamura
is looking at that e4 pawn very very
tempting there's only one play in the
position d5 attacking this knight the
rook would come over to d8 pinning the
knight to the queen
and
does gary have compensation
uh and of course knight c3 castles and
i'm not 100 sure that this full
compensation there
actually the engine is getting white the
edge seriously yeah right at the edge
in that position i couldn't be more
wrong
well we can we can often uh bail out
with with the c7 pawn right ah there's
there's often a snap upon december white
has lots of initiative here and that's
what's justifying it in nakamura
deep into a think
at least a minute he looks like he spent
he went from being a head on the clock
to now being way down on the clock that
last move by gary queen d2 actually the
engine's very first choice gary
defending his pawn preparing the d5
thrust
looks as though it has befuddled
nakamura and he needs to figure
something out very quickly he also has
bishop f3 that runs into bishop to g3
and he has taken queen takes and gary
leans back in shock seeing that move
queen takes on e4
i mean that just simply allows the
winner for peace for a couple of pawns
and he has decided to go for this
position nakamura not wanting to have a
position where he stood worse
strategically as sacrificed his peace
big big decision and i like white's
position yeah the two the two b's
especially uh should give white a clear
edge well he can also get a pawn back on
c7 and that's a huge pawn because that
stops you from rolling with your center
back exactly queen takes d4 knight takes
d4 bishop takes c7 that be an automatic
for me i'm a pawn guy and there's gary
grabbing the phone can anyone say
insufficient compensation
a big decision by nakamura he's going to
have to call on his entire repertoire of
defensive skills to save this one as
gary now has dropped his bishop back and
you saw him screw that piece into the
yeah did you like that twist yes that
was a nice little move there like you
are in trouble sir i'm a piece up the
two bishops are now off the board after
knight takes but
he's got an extra night well it's an
extra bishop on the
board and there's two consoles
totally insufficient uh for the bishop
on g3 this is dominating especially
since we're ganging up in the d5 pawn we
should point out goes down this game
wesley so is dominating currently in his
position against fabiano caruana
so that would close the gap quickly naca
now in trouble our leader in trouble in
this position can he save this game he's
got three pawns it looks like three two
no two balls excuse me two pawns for the
piece
and nice knight
are we gonna have one pawn actually
knight b5 and it will be over
over this is just
i mean bishop f2 is also being given as
a strong move as the strongest move in
the position surprisingly knight b5
allow also wins the pawn but allows king
to see six with some tricks
but he did not play either played
neither of them he played rook to d3 and
now king c6 the knight on e2 he knows
that pawn on d4 looks delish he wants
lunch right now as everybody's ganging
up and black defends and here's the
extra piece the value of the extra piece
and everybody's defending the d4 pawn
it's the only thing holding black's
position together as black is defending
with everything and gary now resetting
rook czech looking to put the rook on c4
right right he's going to put the rook
on c4 instead i was i was surprised he
didn't put his work on a4 originally
because that would have also kept the a
pawn at bay right and now what can
nakamura do to save this position as his
d4 pawn is about to drop and if it does
he'll simply lose the game
this looks completely lost now that's
right i mean i i i actually wouldn't be
surprised if he resigns at some moment
and he's played although nakamura does
not like to give up and he's playing
with b6 right
but that was uh what's funny though
what's funny is this
but guys check this out yes if knight
takes on d4 yes and the king moves yes
how do you unpin yourself
knight takes d4 king anywhere yeah king
a6
how do you unpin yourself
as white you'd have to somehow maybe get
your king to c3
yeah but even that doesn't unfin
yourself how do you unpin
this is what gary is studying right now
how you win the pawn
but you can't on you cannot unpin
yourself and it's cause this is the only
thing that's causing trickery he can't
take the pawn yet that capture creates
too difficult a technical issue to take
on d4 and it is and he decided to not
capture just yet and just play slowly
leave the pawn there it's a weakness for
now so don't bother it and he's just
building his position as now his rook
goes to c7 he's deciding the pawn is a
blockade to black
it's a weakness don't touch it and now
forcing look at that forcing the black
rook over to f8 gary getting more
activity we'll just play for b4 and rook
a3 as well of course
has played very sharp play by kasparov
and now he's just overwhelming the
position this is all him now beautiful
play beautiful play beautiful play
understanding not to take the pawn at
that moment was critical and now naca
realizes that he's busted he's now got
to fight for his life as he plays this
move and here the knight comes back to
the e2 square but now it is a player now
he's won the pawn cold and there it is
rook takes and he's got the second pawn
in his pocket and nakamura is scrambling
now after rook takes work at five look
at five he's down a piece he's got a
piece for one pawn
no this is hopeless this is uh and down
on the clock yeah this has resigned soon
um
a very nice move i like that and wesley
is winning completely at least
so this result will affect the standings
dramatically
a mate threat on the board give us
another pawn he's just grabbing pawns
left and right nakamura and now stunned
right now
it could have been a coronation but it
looks as though he's going to simply
lose the game
offering a trade of rooks and guys this
sets up
finish last round for us
in this ultimate bliss challenge wow
trolling the board with that last move
and now just
knows he's the cat and nakamura is the
mouse right now can he finish him off
still playing as nakamura you know his
defensive skills
here we go check and can he put together
the sequence as nakamura has got two of
his pawns
and the time unlock he's still uh he's
equalized on time now
look at nakamura defend
amazing defense right now the game
the game should be over already but naka
is still defending wesley won his game
setting up for an incredible finish well
that's only if gary wins gary is not
finding the way to win this position a
piece up he has not figured it out now
he's brought his rook backwards to guard
everything and how does he figure out
the wind bishop attacking rook chasing
that away nakamura not giving him any
easy road to win this position and now
he's training rooks there goes a trade
of rooks happening on the board so that
he can play f4 and then advanced with
his king still work the king the black
king looks to go to b4 he's played rook
to c4 doesn't that allow rook
d3
rook d3 rook f4
and he has played it look at f4 and now
his pass f pawn is the story of the
position but there's a pass b pawn
which will be
curtailed after bishop e5 posting up
what
i thought he was going to play king up
in bishop e5 this is
not the technique i would have thought
gary would use but it's winning now now
it is winning that f pawn galloping down
the board really quickly and this is
going to be it rook check chasing the
king away and winning a world war ii
playing spoiler amazing by the king gary
casper
like finally finally i got some luck i
got a break and what jennifer how does
this set us up for
uh the last
more is smiling there laughing as though
it doesn't mean anything that's wesley
in convention but to be fair i mean a
real heroic defense by nakamura i mean i
was actually predicting some resignation
at some point but it just goes to show
you if if nakamura's playing against a
lesser player he may save that his
defense can save i mean
don't give up in blitz and
let's see we've got nakamura and wesley
so we've been a queen of each other and
gary within a point of wesley so gary
and because nakamura and wesley still
play each other in the last round wesley
had the chance to
still
pop this ultimate blitz challenge he
will have black against ikaru in the
last game
he will have black so that's a problem
for him gary could tie wesley if hikaru
wins and that wouldn't be a bad result
after all he would regret the misses he
made but you know it today it doesn't
look as though gary blundered anything
it looks like it was just a regular day
where the other players just played
better that's right
and we do have potential playoff
scenario here if wesley so does win
we've got if we've got a tie for first
place we've got a two game blitz match
same blitz that we've been seeing five
minutes with a three second delay
followed by an armageddon game if
undecided gosh now i i love the way not
gore has been playing but i'm kind of
rooting for wesley to win now because i
do i want to see more of it i know i
feel the same way everybody's rooting
for wesley now more blitz more fun
yeah great stuff hasn't it been jennifer
so go wesley leslie we don't want to
leave just yet exactly one round's gonna
be over in 10 minutes and we could be
here for another hour
the players have really treated us to a
fantastic event this has just been
marvelous to watch i i really am in awe
of what they all have played today and
yesterday it's been great and that game
that wesley so defeated gary kasparov
earlier in the day will go down as one
of the greatest blitz games ever played
and if you want to if he wins this one
that'll be spanx
he will be a true hero but he's got
black against hikaru nakamura that is
not going to be easy at all his hands
are full if i may just show very quickly
just a quick second what happened in the
game against fabiano caron and just this
moment here he played this move knight
to d6 sorry after bishop b5 knight to d6
and picked off an exchange right here
the rook was trapped and that's how he
got his exchange ahead and he just
summarily milked the game after that so
that's how he won his game
now it's time can he do this against the
leader wesley solar already a hero in my
book i mean a lot of people counted him
out of being the champion here in the
ultimate blitz challenge but um he's
shown what he's made of and that um he
can play classical or blitz with the
best alum just fantastic you know we
could practically write a tournament
book on this just on the blitz i mean
that's crazy i mean there's so many
tactics and honestly it's very
instructive the blitz for amateur
players because there's more blunders
and tactics
and we
need to win on demand are we going to
see another queen's gambit declined um
no no no that would be a lot
of an asic slav on the board right now
in knight c3
and bishop f5 so this is giving
a hikaru an opportunity if he wants to
play
an exchange slot with cd5 that's not a
style and he should be true to himself
and not be playing for the draw but just
play for the advantage that's right i
mean especially in blitz and queen b3 is
on the board and rook to a7 that unusual
looking rook move that has become
extremely popular in this line guarding
the b-pawn in the most efficient way and
now knight to h4 attacking the bishop
bishop dropping all the way back
allowing white's bishop to jump
to the d3 square not an opening to show
newcomers to the game rook a7 visit back
to case
wait till your students are 1600 or so
1800 so you teach them anything like
that
at some point black wants to play the
move b5
if allowed so that is something that
white will be on the watch for
but black has to do it just at the right
time and he's taken first
on c4 and played b5
in the position now dropping back is the
bishop
oh he's going to want to follow up b5 at
some point with c5 to unbottle his
pieces that bishop on ca would love to
go to b7 that night on on v8 would love
to come to d7 well it has done so
knight on d7
a4 naka just needs a draw let's keep
that in mind he just needs a draw to win
the tournament and he knows it before a
knight dropping back to b1 and that c4
square is going to be a bit of a problem
and there's c5 as you mentioned jen on
the board now
yeah you'd love to play c5 before
developing the bishop in case you take
but um
save yourself a tempo by recapturing the
interesting situation allowing the
potential isolated pawn and bishop to b7
all of black's pieces he's just a tempo
away from
playing bishop e7 and castles
and now he's decided to go for that
isolated pawn with takes on d4
challenging white after a trade now
bishop takes
and wesley pausing because there is a
capture on e3 to be considered
kind of hard to believe he can play that
move
that he has recaptured the bishop
actually the engines gave detached e3
greed is good as far as engines are
concerned but humans want to play
positional chess and this move not
capturing e3 might have been the chance
that wesley needed but he played very
quickly there without considering the
capture for too long and the engines say
that now he's basically equalized the
position but he could have had an edge
if he had stolen that pawn on e3 that
would have been a big deal it would have
been a big gamble but he might have
needed to do it given the tournament
situation well but there's still some
imbalances in this position so i don't
hate the the scenario for wesley so here
yeah
yeah he's playing against the isolator
queen pawn
keeping the position somewhat in balance
when he's in a muslin situation hard to
see him winning it really is kind of
position
all pieces now he definitely missed a
big chance
he does have like you said the isolated
queen pawn but it gets theoretical in
these kind of positions
and naka as a great defender there he
goes bishop to e3 i think running d5 so
we expect the knight v5 post hina
absolutely
so the classic advantage for black
clearly white no longer is playing for
some real win necessarily
in this kind of position although white
could put the knight somehow to the c5
square 95
probably drop back to d3 and find the c5
square and that's him getting his own
counter play as well
just not easy for black to prove
anything right now and i think naca
knows wesley's gonna have to take a risk
of some kind but it's just not easy to
advance in this position that's right
because we have some weaknesses as well
so if we try to play something like rook
d7 and rook v8 you're always going to
have these pesky 95 modes and well in
any case uh rook b7 was a inactive rook
there was this idea of knight to e5 and
taking control of the c6 square so that
was why
uh wesley felt obliged to trade off a
pair of rooks now this queen c4 why did
i'm a little surprised by that move
queen c4 whoa did wesley play knight
back to b6 he did allowing this move
queen c7
and um
and that did happen
and suddenly the advantage has turned
and i very much like white is back right
now
these positions are very hard to play
and wesley just did not find his best
chance here he has to trade he thought
perhaps that after queen c7 rook c7
maybe he thought that um a4 was dropping
from the position after bishop
even looked at this movie after bishop
d8 were taken on a4 and um we also are
starting to take on b2 but i think you
have a well-timed b3 move absolutely and
so after knight a4 um yeah now you just
play this rook behind this pawn
and now knight takes oh okay i see i
thought you're gonna go the other way
yeah so knight just knight a4 now and
you're just gonna just gonna take batman
b4 yeah
but uh nakamura is pausing he is
considering whether he should stick in
the move b3 and then take the pawn on b4
well
in either case the knight would uh
you know there's a move here the engines
are pointing out the move d5
right now
d5 a crazy idea but the knight is
trapped that knight on a4 is trapped and
nakamura smells the moment there's no
question he's looking at this
opportunity and wondering where it leads
and it's actually quite good for him
this night
gets caged
very tricky situation for wesley right
now he has to be careful that his knight
does not get trapped and the engines are
giving d5 and saying you cannot touch
the pawn on
d5 you have to play bishop f6 nakamura
is studying the moment right now you
know this is the kind of thing you want
to do when there's a moment that it's
that sixth sense he does because d5 is
not the move that you know jumps out at
you and continues the flow exactly it's
a break
has that tactical gifted awareness in
and he's avoided it with rook takes
before he couldn't calculate he offered
a draw and wesley has taken the draw
incredible wesley just decided to bail
out right now it being an equal position
and hikaru nakamura is the champion or
maybe even a bit better for white i
think that's the problem because he's
got more activity in that rook on f8 is
terrible so wesley will be very very
pleased to have him
to have taken second place because now
he cannot get caught uh by carrie
casparo that's right and uh we see that
uh our champion yeah nakamura so let's
turn our eyes on gary kasparov's last
game here in st louis and he's got a big
edge according to the engines he's
completely outplayed fabiano caruana
buckles fabi in this tournament for sure
he's getting outplayed all the games and
black is just dominating the board
there's no real progress
for white possible here looks just
difficult for white to do anything all
of these weaknesses on these light
squares and gary once again in his
element as a fierce attacker
he would love to go out with a win for
sure he will he catch he will not catch
wesley no how would this win about a
clear third place
and winning the winning the game against
naca just now then beating fabi
consolation yeah that's
a tournament nice consolation finish uh
we seen flashes of brilliance by gary
and you know it just goes to show what a
fantastic competitor you you had been
and he retired 11 years ago and in the
first day of play he was pushing these
guys around the board and that that was
an amazing um
amazing performance
and there's gary going after those light
square weaknesses he's just played
bishop f3 setting up all kinds of
checkmating nets what every russian
school board knows
yeah you know you know the funny thing
is fabiano caron was playing the light
square is against him in the last game
so um
black is good yeah
well what gabby did against gary was a
master class i wouldn't say he's uh
luckless uh he too has shown some great
great ability but uh somebody
you know not everybody but somebody has
to take last place
yeah this hasn't been a tremendously
tight tournament though there there was
remember we came in today with any of
the four players really um with
realistic chances of taking down this
challenge absolutely we just see this
move c
d4 d5 by
by
knight e5
and he had to take that knight that
knight is just too powerful this looks
like an overwhelming attack to my eyes
that's right now 91 desperately trying
to um guard the f3 square so that in the
event of bishop g2 king g2 you you don't
have to worry about h3 and queen f3 it
was ending the story exactly
but this is just a direct attack yes it
just seems straightforward a queen to h5
would be a nice move he's taking on g3 i
think he has to take with the f pawn
though just yes just to save his life
otherwise
he might
h5
taking with the f pawn is probably
forced but then that e3
uh pawn is going to be
uh
tenderized with bishop h6 and knight g4
and he has taken with the f1 and
recognizing uh the reality of
how difficult it is as a position that's
right because it's not just the bishop
on h6 it's also the knight coming to g4
and there you go we see i mean
how quickly
gary can pounce on the position is it's
really remarkable look at this king g7
by gary so that if knight g4 at least
you can hang on by a thread with rook b3
i'm gary bringing in another piece with
bishop h6 with king g7
just setting up a potential rook h8
what is gary thinking about rook h8
doesn't work right now because
well is he going to play knight takes
allow knight takes on d6
can he do that rook
he'll throw an a6 first maurice just
drive the knight back he was hovering
over his rook but now he's changing his
mind when he's starting with the move
queen h5 remember that
he can play knight g4 earlier yeah we we
thought definitely queen h5 and knight
g4 but the move a6 was much stronger
according to the engines and this one
much weaker but no actually he's still
in it he's still there with
opportunities because the a pawn
according to the engines is this is not
too deep in analysis the eight pawn is
hanging but nobody's gonna take that
ball of d7 forget that there's mating
ideas you have to worry about on the
other side of the board and now he's
playing good move by if abby h3 yes he's
making it tough yeah he's trying to heal
his position no question about it and
another nice move by gary knight h7
trying to post up his knight on
to the
g5 square so that he can attack this
pawn on h3 and now desperation mode by
five he's played e4
a tremendous sacrifice by casparo and
he's going to bring all his pieces near
that king no queen trays allowed forget
about that lean to g3 now automatically
look at that no and now the pawn on e3
is hanging with check and the rook is
coming in the game the knight is coming
in the game a beautiful sacrifice by
kasparov and he is completely winning
now here comes the knight g5 and what
are you going to do something heads up
the check threats are coming this is
over that's right we got a fabi is
running but unfortunately it's going to
be a hard to run which one gary
where are you
check and gary sees the whole
combination as he has brought
he's played the check the king over
bishop and he's taking the knight traded
that last piece off
right now
[Music]
nakamura and caruana
really after hanging a lot of nights he
showed such great night play in that
game so really a beautiful end and it's
wonderful to see uh gary's motion
your pure emotion just happiness i
played a great game in the finish office
after playing so much wonderful chats
exactly
and let's take a look at our champion of
the ultimate blitz challenge see caro
nakamura he gets twenty thousand dollars
for first place with a a big ten and a
half
score
ten and a half points out of eighteen
eight actually not that big
so you you could have predicted that
somebody might have gotten an even
bigger score at the beginning of that
one
oh eleven actually that was a miss point
sorry guys so yeah eleven points out of
eighteen wesley so picking up 15k for
his efforts with 10 points gary kasparov
generously donating his ten thousand
dollar prize to u.s chess team in the
olympia which is going to be a super
strong team with these guys and our u.s
champion fabiano carolina
um five and a half points
that's right so we have 10k going to
that olympic team and our u.s champion
um not finishing first in this
competition but he's with maurice right
now to talk about
the twists and turns
[Music]
with u.s champ fabiano caruana having a
tough day today for sure scoring two
points out of nine
fabi is it hard to get real motivation
to play in this tournament after you've
won a u.s championship
how seriously did you take this event
how much did you prepare for it
i didn't really prepare but i'm not sure
if anyone
actually prepared very much at all um i
mean i didn't want to do well and it
it was just a bit of a nightmare um
starting from like round six
what what do you think went wrong here
um
well everything
no i mean the games i think were just
very bad
uh when you're losing like that you see
you do you feel like what's going on in
my fingertips my moves are not coming
fast enough and accurately enough
yeah the thing i mean it can also happen
in classical chess but in blitz it's
uh it happens so much more suddenly and
it's really hard to stop it um
i mean the game just come one after the
other if you're not playing well it's
very easy to lose a bunch in a row
but it happens
also from time to time in long games
where you just don't know what you're
doing
tough day
last question for you
gary kasparov i mean he looked shaky at
points
but he really looked amazing at some
points what was your impression seeing
how he played
yeah he's still a very strong player i
don't think that
really came as a surprise to anyone
i mean especially blitz he still has
fantastic instincts
so
i mean those really go a long way
and
i mean opening preparation and
knowledge of current opening trends and
what's happened for the past decade
is much less relevant so he um
he does occasionally blunder
he's
definitely a lot weaker a lot louder a
lot bigger than at his peak but um
he's still a very very good player
as are you we know that this was blitz
and anything could happen but you still
remain the u.s champion we look forward
to seeing your future tournaments and
shake this one off and enjoy the time in
tampa as you get ready for your next
events which we will be looking forward
to thank you the u.s champion fabiano
carwana a difficult day for him but
still the champ
thank you fabi jen overall impressions
of this second day of action
what what what do you think well i think
it's really it's all about wesley's
first game and because that that was
just like such a stunner right one for
the books i mean you really could show
that game alongside morphe's game i mean
one of the reasons i wrote play like a
girl was that i said hey you can show
some of these same themes at the classic
show
with women champions games and you can
show some of the same themes at the
classic show with the games of the top
american players absolutely and i think
that's very inspiring to children to see
like hey wesley can come in say hello
and give assignment at my school and he
can also play one of the best games i've
seen we're talking kids who have just
started and against
the hero himself
yes wesley
that game will certainly
open up a lot of eyes as to what a great
talent wesley uh so is and we're just
getting uh set up in our studio for our
second guest that's right and what about
you i mean nakamura also we really i he
said he didn't like the way you played
yesterday and i had to kind of agree i
feel like respect even more from this
blitz legend but today he showed what he
was made of really uh hikaru impressed
uh absolutely absolutely he he he was
playing uh the best chess in the second
uh leg of this tournament without
question you deserve winner and
deserving winner and the only huge
blemish was that lost to gary caspara
but even in that game he made it tough
down an entire piece for like no
compensation and he still was like hey
you still have to beat me exactly
and we've got wesley so and you know
everybody was clapping at the end of
your game wesley
we we needed some coins to throw
he's with maurice ashley
yes with the second place finisher
wesley so after playing simply an
amazing morphe-esque game in game one
beautiful attacking chess you came in
today with great aspirations wesley
first of all let's talk about this game
did you did you feel how powerful it was
when you played the game
again which the game against gary no
first round the one where you played
with c5 and b4 and and sacked on e5 with
a knight and then sack on c6 with a rook
and i'm going to be showing that one to
my students for years to come ah thank
you well um it's incredible because
usually it's
almost impossible to do something like
this when you only have five minutes on
the clock but at the same time gary also
only has five minutes on the clock so
i'm sure he had a better defense
somewhere
but uh over blitz it's not easy with
your king and castle even if he was up
two pawns
so yeah b5 was a blunder because i was
intending to take on e5 anyway
but now he's giving me a free pawn
so instead b5 we should have done a5 but
then it would be eight and then i didn't
want to give my bishop so i went bishop
a4
and it's
pretty hard to make any moves in this
position when you have two minutes left
on the clock it's difficult because i'm
also turning knight h4 for instance
just spreading the defense tremendous
tremendous game like we said we were in
shock we were hard it was hard to do
commentary after you played this game we
just wanted to stop the tournament for a
little while
analyze just this game alone yeah and
then to do this against uh immortal gary
kasparov it's just incredible it really
was incredible but then
you you
kind of caught a little hiccup somewhere
in the middle was against nakamura maybe
yes it was uh i mean i i lost
um my white game against him and i lost
wait i think i lost two games against
him today
i lost my white game yeah and then you
lost the next one to him as well yes so
that was unfortunate um
he played the same variation
as he did yesterday in the queen's
gambit declined and he has some
improvement and some new ideas of a
setup and then i simply became too
passive and too
comfortable in my position i thought no
i have a solid position and then
suddenly he took my pawn on b4 right a
trick when you put your key on f1
and the thing here in blitz is that uh
you can never
sacrifice pawns or pieces just just like
that and so
after that i had no chances and that's
unfortunate because it was clearly a an
important game for the final standing
now many players weren't putting you as
one of the favorites in the event nobody
had really seen you play
too much blitz
how did you practice for this event
well i it's not so easy i played online
blitz but it's not the same playing
online and playing over the board and
also i'd like to thank uh
alex slenderman
for helping me before this blitz by
offering to play some bits with me and
we did and uh
it just got me warmed up
but
how could alex linderman prepare you for
gary casparo fabiana caruana
i mean alex is a good player
yes that's why i was kind of shocked and
i lost my first two games in this
tournament because i didn't realize
simply how how powerful my opponents
were and i didn't expect gary to
to play this the same uh exciting
energetic chess as us as he did before
but he played extremely well
and uh i was fortunate to save uh
a lot of games against him you stole a
couple of nights there from otherwise
the result could have been flipped and
two days in in two games yes but today
he was watching out for his knights very
well
yeah it was it was your sacrificing
pawns that that under
cut him
last question for you do you want to
play more of these blitz events do you
think that they're fun to play on a
professional level
yes well they are definitely fun and
exciting especially since gary
very graciously accepted to to play here
if
you know it's a big thing that he
decided to play of course keep his
prize winnings for the u.s olympiad team
that was really not a great thing for
him to do um
i believe it's exciting but it also
requires a lot of preparation from the
players
um
you know i simply cannot uh play this
every day and expect to
to play well but we have the
grand chester coming up in
two months i believe or in less than two
months and that's right in june
beginning june 8th
yeah in paris i'll be there as well with
you guys having fun paris and brothel
speaking of which we just
got our ticket to that today so we will
see you there
um
yes blitz just can be an
exciting uh supplement for for classical
chess although of course uh
uh with five minutes again we cannot
avoid making tons of mistakes
mistakes do happen
the fans love it and the fans love you
always gracious thanks so much for
joining us and congratulations on your
second place finish thank you
congratulations to the winner
grandmaster wesley so one of the nicest
players you'll ever meet
absolutely great performance today
i will
remain in awe of that blitz game
for the rest of my life i just thought
watching that unfold was unbelievable
and
the dynamic
aggression that wesley showed in that
game sacrificing one pawn two pawns the
knight the rook it was just
poetry yeah it was gorgeous um i i
really loved the way he started with
that b4 and the amazing thing was gary
casper for us you know gary casper
already realized what was happening
after before yes he realized the
impending dream
you know i mean that he was on the
receiving end of a brilliancy
that's right although it took it took a
lot more time for the fans and the
spectators to see what was going to
happen
as soon as before happened he started
shaking his eye exactly he knew there
was his spidey sense started tingling
but some brilliant games by gary
kasparov today as well and he's with
maurice to talk about the second
thrilling day here in st louis
our third place finisher gary kasparov
with just some electrifying chess
both days of the tournament undercut by
his blunders the three nights gambit i'm
sure you'll remember these three nights
for a while but you did play some real
satisfying games tell us what it felt
like to play two days of chess against
three of the best chess players in the
world um
it was a tough night actually because i
just couldn't uh
get rid of this horrors you know these
blunders actually this is the worst
memory of yesterday was not a blunder by
the way i played against wesley so
probably had a psychological impact on
me so that's why i played so poorly
against him today ironically you know i
want two two micro matches you know just
as if somebody would have told me before
the beginning that i could beat hikaru
in in in six games match and to lose
i i i wesley i mean i don't think
anybody would would believe in it um
and um i um
um i just i was thinking what was knight
on d6 you know this is the night of this
totally paralyzed black's position and i
could do whatever so just
um and it's you know
i didn't also know what to do today
because you know i thought should i try
to play just to win or just there were
many you know many problems and that's
probably the the most important one is
that you know i'm i was out of you know
professionals just for so long so that's
why you know actually playing these guys
you know and just you know realizing
that you know i have to be you know um
it's very so serious preparing and you
know knowing that it's just to win the
game it takes
much more than just you know winning a
game because they will fight you know to
the very very end so um and i you know
as you can see you know this is the the
first game i played very very poorly so
with wesley uh it's a good irony because
you know i you know he sacrificed the
porn which was a very dubious sacrifice
if i played instead of b6 b5 you know i
just had an extra pawn and okay he had
some compensation but it would be a
different ball game and the morning i
played b6 and i just ah and then i just
immediately made a second mistake with
bishop c6 that's what what happens and
then it's just after before it's you
completely lost so i just you know and
he did he finished very very nicely but
beautiful game it's a beautiful game but
it's just you know that's it reminded me
of the game morphy played with amateur
so that's why you know and i was on the
side okay i was an amateur in this game
yeah it's just
it was yeah it was a total disaster so
it's about again it's a nice game so but
um and uh i know the good thing is that
i could recover so and it's the and the
last round so after this miracles you
know um uh game was with wesley when i
just saved a totally lost end game as i
actually i was about to resign you know
a couple of times but you know but then
you know we just
missed a few wins and then suddenly i
created chances so when it's you know
it's it's it always happened in blitz so
that's why he got panicked you know and
maybe even the final position he could
still go rook c1 but it's just it was
already you know it was rough on b1 he
wasn't sure so i and uh after i saved
the game i said let's let's try again
and then hikaru you know uh was very
gracious because you know he
uh he just played a very bad move bishop
d4 and then gave up a piece i don't know
why so that's this was was totally you
know just uh um
unexplainable to me that allowed you to
win the last two games and you seem
quite satisfied that last game you
played against bobby was a nice little
attack actually last game you know it's
just it's sometimes you know this is the
old memories it's just being revived you
know i play this this move bishop by
five it's against uh um
against the british player web it was
the first round of european team
championship in 1980
uh and it was my first action game for
the for the soviet national squad so
that was the second reserve you know so
and uh he played d4 e4 and knight uh i
think he played g5 rookie eight and it's
just you know and i was very proud with
bishop f5 because it allowed me to meet
d4 with e4 so and i want a very nice
game so he's knight actually you know i
was rotten h3 i just pushed it there i
uh
the way
carolina played i mean just was you know
it was so easy for black because you
know i could you know i could build you
know my momentum there just you know and
it just reminded me the last game i
played with nigel here because it's also
having you know all the pieces there so
it was easy so easy but you know still
you know i enjoyed it you know um and
just i like the moment when i could
sacrifice my yeah sort of push you know
g4 just keep all the pawns you know out
of the board and then just to have the
final attack and then rook h8 king j8
bishop afraid it was nice it's very nice
okay nice finish so it's the okay i'm
quite happy again as i said i want two
micro matches i ended plus one so again
i um
i did better than that many expected so
i again i didn't i didn't i don't know
yes i thought you're going to win the
whole thing
look you know yesterday i missed my
chance so this is just it's because you
know it's you you can go on expl
analyzing it but but yesterday i missed
real you know really big chance so this
is um uh winning you know uh just not
blundering this tonight so just you know
scoring probably a point and a half
again so in these two games that would
be a very different match uh very
different tournament for me absolutely
we see that you're giving your winnings
to the u.s olympic team tell us why you
felt that would be a good idea look i
guess this is i'm i'm i'm an amateur i'm
not professional player so i just you
know i think it's you know it's the they
they were gracious they wanted to play
this event and this is i thought it
would be nice you know if if i make the
donation so okay i i hope it will be a
bigger donation
[Laughter]
but whatever it is it goes to the team
and i wish them good luck and baku well
we absolutely appreciate that uh your
hometown about kuwait in fact
so will we see more of gary caspar
playing blitz after all the openings
don't seem to matter as much all this
opening development over the last 10
years it's all about instinct it's all
about understanding chess you seem to be
rising to the occasion showing those old
skills
a lot more blitz from you you know it's
right now just you know being fresh
after two straight victories against uh
uh nakamura
yeah i mean you know to in yes yes yes
but you know just uh remembering you
know my emotions last night you know
this morning so i'm not so sure look you
know
now
i think it does i
i think i proved that i could play
against them so it's a lot of fun so and
yeah maybe again but
i probably need you know if if i if i
uh uh if if i take the challenge again
you know i would do probably a more
serious preparation because you know you
have so many things you know floating in
the head you know at my age you know
your family you have other things and i
have lectures you know i have writings i
do you know a lot of stuff on on twitter
on facebook and so there's a political
uh appearances and then you just have to
think about scotch you know and then you
have to think about other things and
it's just and you know it's it's the
problem is you know this is this many
positions is difficult for me to play
because you know it's
because i i don't have this practice so
this is they are they place some
positions so often like you know the the
berlin or classical lopez or
uh uh queen's gambit yeah i i mean i
know how to play them but in blitz it's
very difficult you know that you know
just to um to take this challenge uh
because you know it's it's all about
instincts and you know they're much
better
prepared for that so
if it happens again so i will probably
you know
look at you know some some some other
ideas but you know it's when i when i
you know when i had my chance to to
attack and just you know to sacrifice
some material so i did well yeah you did
more than well you quoted yourself
brilliantly
i've been calling your
games and matches since 1994 and it's
always a pleasure to see you play and
seeing you now in fine form is excellent
we want to see more of it absolutely i
think the fans are calling for it gary
kasparov thank you so much for joining
us and hosting this event thank you
former world champion gary kasparov
showing that old form boy you do not
want to put a king in his face he will
crack it for sure
simply great chess and yeah we want him
to play more chess
thank you maurice and gary
day one it was the gary kasparov show i
mean we were just mesmerized by his play
in the first day like he said
he missed some crucial opportunities in
that first day
and that allowed opened the door wide
open to wesley and
uh hikaru that's right and uh our
champion nakamura we're getting him set
up now and uh yeah that final game that
gary played though leading a lasting
impression it's just such a sweet taste
to end a tournament absolutely with that
absolutely and just
he shows what he's capable of but a man
who we knew coming in
was an extraordinary blitz specialist
and
just
the best blitz player the world has ever
seen in my opinion is hikaru nakamura
and he is uh
he's making some faces
he's making faces but we're about to get
him on camera so keep making those faces
nakamura congratulations absolutely
congratulations zakar
hikaru nakamura one of the top 10
players in the world
blitz has been his calling card for
years and years and many thought he was
going to be the favorite to win this
event he did deliver on that first of
all
congratulations on first place thanks
after yesterday you felt shaky you said
it didn't seem like you were playing
your best chest for sure but you were
still tied at the top
today you seem to have your game face on
from the very first round
what was your attitude what did it shift
going into today that this was not an
exhibition event but it was time for you
to win this tournament i mean i don't
think it was that i think it's just
yesterday i was not seeing anything like
every game yesterday i was losing at
some point there's no doubt about that
and i mean okay if you play one bad game
two three and you know it can happen but
to just be like much worse loss in every
single one i mean it just wasn't wasn't
wasn't there yesterday um but today yeah
today things things went i mean a lot
better for me so it's pretty smooth i
would say how does that happen how does
the switch just go off one day
everything's going badly the next day
suddenly you're a genius
i mean that happens to everyone you have
your good days and your bad days um but
but i think today more importantly um i
mean there's there's one player who who
really didn't play well today i think
that was fabiano and and because of that
i mean several of us were able to rack
up a lot of points and that's i mean
what made the difference i mean i i
played fine against wesley i did well
against him i did not do so well against
gary obviously um despite some good
positions so
uh so yeah it was pretty balanced but i
took advantage of the opportunities when
they arose today especially your
defensive skills were really on call
against gary that one game
that you played when he when he played
knight g3 well i was a little bit
fortunate in that one but i mean the
first game of the day against gary where
i was black i was quite quite happy with
the way i defended because i think uh
gary's preparation was quite good for
this event and that it wasn't i mean
okay obviously chess has changed you
can't just win games out of the opening
but he he did find ways to create
positions where it was much easier for
him to play uh than it was for us and
and when that happens in normal normal
games i mean it's it's it's a challenge
but when it happens in blitz where you
don't have a lot of time to figure out
it becomes especially tricky and so i
mean i thought gary gary was quite good
at that today i mean and
and i mean
he probably should have finished in
second i think what are your thoughts
about kasparov playing more chess do you
think it's great for the game that he's
playing in these blitz events showcasing
his old skills yeah it's it's always a
good thing i think um
i mean i think the main thing is it's
clear that you know he he's not uh you
know he's not
he's not done he's still quite
competitive um
and i i think if he's competitive i
don't know why he shouldn't play i mean
i think playing normal terms of course
takes too much time and it's it's uh
it's a real grind uh especially at his
age but still i mean he's a competitive
player in these exhibitions uh i don't
see any reason why he's shown i think
it's very good for trust your feeling
about winning this event you did
not do as well in the u.s championship
as you might have hoped there were there
was one with two games you didn't like
in the u.s championship that decided it
for you
but you wanted to win this of course
yeah i i mean to not win something here
would have been a little bit
disappointing uh but but i'm just happy
that i was able to play well today
because i feel like the last couple days
i mean i've just been like starting to
lose it a little bit just too much chess
since since you know february so uh it's
kind of the end of a long long long
series of tournaments i'm just happy
that i was able to win win today and uh
and now i can relax for a few months a
few months what's your next tournament
well maybe it's not a few months i guess
it's the grand chess tour in june
june 5th or something but i mean i've
i've been on the road since like early
january from i have i haven't been uh
been at home since then so it's just uh
it's been a lot of trust a lot of
traveling i mean a lot of a lot of ups
and downs i mean candidates especially
so i'm just glad that i can get a break
now
well the life of a professional chess
player of course it's never done their
tournaments to play but you are now the
champion of this tournament and
congratulations on showcasing your
skills today thanks maurice hikara
nakamura the winner of ultimate blitz
showing why he's simply one of the best
plus players on the planet thank you
maurice and our again congratulations to
hikaru for an outstanding performance he
uh
he gave us a lot of thrills i would say
in this event
absolutely all the games i mean it was
almost like every round was filled with
thrills and spells absolutely you know
it could barely catch your breath as you
pointed out after that was a game oh
yeah
i'm still reeling so i mean real big
thanks to all the players and um you
know especially uh gary for agreeing to
come to retirement to play this yes
what a challenge think about the
challenge what do you say yeah i mean
these three opponents in my mind
uh are three of six of the best players
in the world and to accept that
challenge after a 11-year hiatus is not
easy and he really acquitted himself the
only thing we need to make it the best
thing of all time would be to add magnus
in the banks absolutely who did win in
norway you did yeah that's wonderful and
i've heard that um and maurice ashley
your final thoughts
well this was simply a thrill to
commentate on a tremendous event gary
kasparov showing his old skills
joyous brilliant at the end of it
winning against fabi and nakamura in the
last two rounds
he's definitely a champion we want to
see play more and more and of course the
three players who competed against him
three of the finest players in the
united states they will be representing
us in the olympiad and his generous
donation will certainly go a long way to
seeing that maybe we'll win it all win
gold
but it was golden today what a great
experience i'm grateful to be a part of
it and everyone here in saint louis it's
been a long road for us as well we did
the u.s championship doing commentary
for that and now these two days but it's
always fun and i look forward to joining
us joining the team again and
paris that's going to be the next big
one for us i'll be packing my bags and
getting my beret on get that baguette in
croissants
i'll see you guys next time thanks so
much uh for having me and and this great
team that's right i mean we've had um
you know over a hundred thousand viewers
yesterday and you know we really got to
thank our crew here a lot of people talk
about how amazing this event was but
the production value that shows you all
those beautiful shots all those great
graphics by eric the montage scenes yeah
all the intro
pieces yeah so we got really got to
thank spectrum studios randy singfield's
company because we've got um jen marcus
eric liz justin so many people brian tom
kite tammy so many people literally
working around the clock to make this
production beautiful for you absolutely
thank you very very much for the
outstanding work and we are going to be
back in paris and brussels and we can't
wait for you guys to join us again you
know
that's right stay tuned for the grand
chess tour in just a month and a half we
are going to have magnus carlsen playing
in that as well as the top three players
from the us chess championship so enjoy
your month and a half off and uh we'll
see you in june thanks everybody here at
the st louis chess club and of course to
all of our our fans and viewers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you